Company I made 12 bucks an hour,
but that's all I need.
I live with a small apartment on the
street.
I don't go out too much.
I like to watch TV.
I can't afford a car.
I use public transportation.
I don't mind.
I read until I reach my destination.
Sometimes a newspaper,
sometimes the amount of money at save
the shit is off the hook end up.
Not every good with the women.
I'm a pretty sharp person and an average
look.
Last time I had sex was in 2003 in a
machine,
but it wasn't free.
I'm just regular everyday.
Normal guy.
I get nervous in social situations about
the and regular normal guy.
I can't concentrate and once a month
mother fuck us to regular normal guy and
I make pretty good spaghetti sauce.
Motherfuckers to break the law and
Bridgette,
normal guy and I get scared.
Cool.
See the fences?
Pauly,
pauly.
Shore of everyday life can be and he
doesn't know about it.
No,
I know he does.
His buddy.
I'm too busy.
Manager wanted me to do something like
is some specialty was doing.
I'm like,
he does not know.
He's never heard.
Anything I've done just wants you
because you're,
you becoming famous.
Yara joined on the podcast today by
Genre Lushwala.
That is the correct pronunciation,
sir.
I got it right.
Thank you.
It sounds sexy.
Fantastic comedian from Montreal,
Canada,
Montreal,
one of my favorite cities in the world.
Uh,
before we even get started,
we're sponsored by the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe Rogan dotnet and enter
in the code name Rogan,
you get 15 percent off.
Have you ever used one of those things
by uh,
you know what,
I'm going to be weird.
I've used like A.
I don't know if it's a competitor thing,
like I haven't,
but I could,
you know,
any birth.
I mean,
how could you not know if you guys have
for me?
Should definitely,
I'd love to.
I love this one has been around and
everybody's been finger in it since the
beginning of the year,
so we're going to have to get you a new
one now.
I'll take that one.
It's the first time.
I don't want to be caught at home with
the butthole version.
At least you get caught with the vagina
version.
It's like,
yeah,
you're a pervert,
but you know,
whatever.
If you just run around just hey,
it's just tighter,
better Robert Bundles better.
Right?
Tighter girls are better just.
But what it represents,
man represents girls.
You want to fuck girls on the butts,
so bad,
fake one and not even like the rest of
the girl attached to it.
You don't even have a fake body.
You just have the fake bundle.
It just stuffed it in that fake
butthole,
like some fucking feet,
but sex fiend,
a way to sell them and it's a fucking
fantastic thing though.
Here.
It feels like put your fingers when no
one has had sex with a couple of dudes
of fingertip think Eddie Bravo licked
his finger before he stuck it in there.
Oh yeah.
Weird.
Right?
Like,
I don't care what Saturday.
Me fucking this fucking my hands.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's a weird thing though.
It,
it's,
it's most certainly absolutely
embarrassing.
It's embarrassing to allow people buying
it would be the worst,
but now you can get online,
which is.
It's like they only get you with stuff
like that.
If you get embarrassed by it,
then it becomes a shameful thing.
Like if someone comes in my office and
goes,
fuck this thing,
do you fuck this thing?
I'd be like,
yeah,
yeah.
Fuck it.
Like,
what do you care?
You know,
you can't get me with that.
But to a lot of people know,
you say to them,
Hey,
what do you fucking that tube over
there?
And they get red and they feel like a
loser.
I can't let other motherfuckers define
you.
Ladies and gentlemen.
That's my message.
All right,
fuck that.
Fuck that tube son.
Fuck it.
My cleaning lady just like,
she comes in and like,
I have shit,
you know,
that tissues should not even just like,
just like stuff,
you know,
some fun toys that I use with some.
Oh Lady Dildos and shit.
God damn man goes deep cleaning lady.
She's like,
she'll clean my plate and this will be
like,
oh.
She'll find them and just put them on
top of a dresser.
Like it'd be like,
what the fuck is that like for her
picking up your dirty,
slimy frosted?
It looks like a donut,
like frosted donut.
Deldot clean.
Just lying on the bed recently.
Have you noticed like girls,
like,
like different girlfriends don't like
using like old dildos.
Like with the.
I always had the girls.
Well I started to like try to put them
in nights,
own packaging and stuff like that.
No mother fucker.
That's ridiculous.
How much is the Dildo that only like
$10.
I buy good ones.
You know like the whatever,
the dolphins and the Dolphin.
It's like $90.
That's like the playstation of fucking
deal that girls like this has been
inside some other girl's pussy with you
and like push shoving it in there.
Like she doesn't want his fingers.
They're washed.
That's good points.
These are,
it is a good point but it doesn't matter
because it's still your body and somehow
or that it makes it okay.
Yeah.
Some rubber,
rabbit,
rabbit and asshole at the same time it
was a rabbit.
It's worse also that you bought it
specifically to fuck some other girl
with it.
Like it wasn't like,
oh,
I found this lying around and I just
fucked this other girl is like,
you bought it with this other sugars and
fucked her with it,
and then you're like,
oh,
I'm not with her anymore and now I'm
with this other.
You got to be careful getting into that
fucking robotics world.
No,
she fucking setting a pace.
You can't really match up with what you.
A chip with one of those rabbit things
and it's beating the fuck out of the
sides of her pussy and just Anderson
Silva knee and the size of her buzzy.
Just slamming it down.
That little rabbit ears or janitor and
her butthole.
What do you do with your average Dick?
Human.
Yeah.
What are you gonna do with that fleshy
little soft thing that you know that
you've got to worry about?
If she gets on top,
she might break it down.
It happened,
man,
where it almost breaks when you get a
fallout and then it hits the tank.
Pulls that dude.
God's got to the hospital for this shit.
Are you serious?
Yes.
You can tear your,
your Dick Breaks and not only does it
break,
but a lot of times it stays crooked
forever.
Oh,
I think I broke my dick before that.
But you did,
man.
I bet.
I think I broke mine a little.
I didn't think it was possible,
so I always just went,
ah,
yeah,
because it's going to break over time.
An old ship fucking hit too many rocks.
It looks like a broken naive man.
Spilt beer,
rotten.
A deck.
A lot of waves hitting the left side.
There's this dude.
I'm my message board.
I fucking.
I'm sorry man.
I forget your name,
but he's a.
He has a fucking giant hog and his
pictures like totally bent digs,
like completely bent to the right,
so much so that it subverted and that's
his name on the message board.
It's so.
His Dick is so ridiculous.
It looks like it's photoshop.
I mean there's no way it could be that
fat because he's a little dude,
giant Dick and no way.
It could be taking such a hard angle and
he sends it to chicks and created some
drama line because he sent it to some
girls,
sent you a picture of his dick,
puts them online,
man.
Guy Put them online for everybody to
see.
I would love to have my dick like
pointed up,
like bent up.
So it just hit the top of the girls.
How many pictures have you seen online
of the dudes that you know?
I'm really.
I mean
no,
I mean on the message board.
Everybody's fortunately more impersonal
because we hang out with comics.
Is it like that John is from Montreal,
Canada?
Is it,
is it like that up there to do with
their dicks out all the time or is it
too cold?
I think it's a little,
but I had a buddy who had the prince
Albert thing.
Oh,
a piercing of whipping on his dick and
show the fuck is up with that guy.
Seriously.
Had some fucking crazy shit.
I've never looked at my ticket.
Thought about throwing some metal
through it,
like a hole through the tear.
What are you fucking like?
Whoa.
Cut Open like a sausage.
Have you seen everything?
No,
no,
no.
It's another one.
There's like a ring like right through
the tip of the Prince Albert,
but the other one that you're talking
about as a more of a body modification,
they cut into the penis and they slice
it open like a hot dog.
It's common.
It's really common.
So what.
Okay.
So is the whole hot dog in a microwave?
What spreads must just spray all over
the fucking place.
I have no control over the pis.
You know,
it looks horrendous to.
It looks terrifying.
But bb t here like.
Yeah.
Cool.
Yeah,
some Weirdo just wants to change the way
looks.
You'd have a listening to some fucking.
I Dunno.
Indie rock albums.
Records Dude.
Butcher your Dick.
That's a weird thing man.
It's a weird thing when you know,
it's like where do draw that line?
You know when you see a chick with a lip
ring,
like,
whoo,
you gotta ring on your lip,
your upper lip,
there's a ring on it,
a metal ranked.
How far are you willing to go because
you're already in crazy town.
You've already got the staples in your
face.
Who fucking free?
What are you doing?
You ever a girl with the clit ring?
That's Kinda cool though.
It's kind of cool,
but it also kind of seems like she's a
mess.
Oh go.
And you know what you're getting.
If you're decorating down there,
it's because you have open houses all
the time.
Going down here.
I'm like,
wait a minute,
dude.
You gotta write that down.
That's an ad Lib.
Shit.
That's a bit.
Don't forget that one will hold.
We'll hold here.
Okay.
That's it.
That's a god damn genius beer.
That's hilarious.
It is.
There's a thing about girls with clit
rings.
You got to know that if a girl's
decorating down there,
she's having open houses all the time.
Know that Shit,
man.
Okay,
I see.
I can't sit down and write comedy and
then all of a sudden I just fucking.
I do the same thing,
man.
I have ideas and I have to slam them
onto a piece of paper or I have to get
it down as quick as possible too because
five minutes later I'm like a fucking
idiot savant.
I don't know what I said.
That's why these podcasts are actually
pretty good because you can actually
write comedy while you're talking.
There's so many times.
Yeah,
I just spiderman talking about spiderman
where it's me throwing come on walls of
hotels and I do it on stage now and it
fucking kills.
That's great.
If you do that for real.
He's a mess.
Motherfucker.
Walls that you and I have to go and
touch.
No,
you're in your underwear and you're
putting your socks on.
You might lean against the wall.
Could easily be touching.
This creeps loads even worse.
I played chicken.
I throw it on the ceiling and keep my
mouth open and play with someone else
for yourself.
Whereas if I start out of the way,
but I don't and that's why I get id for
cigarettes.
Look my skin.
So that is an excuse for you to be gay
for yourself.
I'm not playing a part of this play come
chicken with like,
how fucking gay gay that's like,
no,
it's just recycling.
It's just bizarre.
Jim Norton and says,
great bit about this chick that used to
make them do things like she.
I guess it's his girlfriend.
She tells him what to do and you know,
she used to be a dominatrix or something
nutty like that and Jim comes on her
tits and she makes him lick it up and
it's a true story and he's talking about
and it fuck oh delirious.
But it's also your fucking toes curl up.
Your butthole crunches up.
You closed your nostrils when you hear
it,
your whole body like construction,
like don't eat your own.
Something about.
It's just you guys.
Men.
We're talking to you on one of the
podcasts this week.
Some guy was.
Who was was if adf did effect a funny
guy.
Yeah.
He was talking about some guy sucking
some guy or letting some guys suck his
dick so that he could fuck this hot
chick.
Oh,
it's great.
Yeah.
That was that eft friended that.
Yeah,
and you're like,
my manager tells me the story of him
body were they hooked up with these two
chicks in,
throughout the hotel room with these two
chicks and the two chicks,
like start like making out and
everything and they go,
you guys make out.
We will lucky and I just do eric.
You guys have to make out my managers.
Just like,
all right,
fuck it.
I'm out of here.
And the guys chasing him around the room
going,
stop being such a such a
fucking pussy dude.
Just make out with me dude though.
These like,
fuck man,
how bad you need to get lady Korea.
Need a scar in your brain for life
because the moment you know the moment
you,
what the fuck have I done?
He would immediately recognize the
depths of your depravity and I think I'd
let someone,
some guys suck my Dick.
Make out with a more intimate.
I don't know,
man.
Up Stop.
You can control yourself.
I mean you're.
You can defend yourself.
Some dude has his mouth over your Dick.
He can just clamp down on that thing at
any moment.
And at the end of your Dick.
Yeah,
that's true.
Fuck all that.
When Saturday night live do it thing
because there's so many people live with
the fuck he talking about.
I mean like everybody is sucking Dick on
Saturday and they make out with each
other and shit.
Right?
Then there's a live studio audience is
different than being like,
okay,
there's a lot of guys that think it's
funny to just be nutty like that,
you know,
that was a big thing the hell's angels
used to do in the sixties.
Hunter s Thompson wrote about it.
About how in that,
uh,
the,
the um,
the hell's angels book that he wrote,
he wrote about how they would try to
freak out squares.
Like when they were around like regular
people,
they would just start making out with
each other big burly guys like tongue
and all that.
Just whoa.
Hey,
there's all these video of it.
It's the documentary Gonzo great
documentary narrated by a Johnny Johnny
Depp.
Super Inspirational,
makes you want to write.
And it makes you really appreciate his,
his whole outlook on things.
And also recognize him for real.
Like they didn't try to make him look up
anything other than what he was like,
it's flawed,
brilliant but flawed,
crazy all over the place.
But look what he produced,
you know,
it was like one of those things.
But it was also like,
look how he fell.
Like,
look,
look how it all fell apart for him.
Look how his career,
all the uphill battles he said,
yeah,
it's scary shit man.
Because you know,
as uh,
any,
any artist I think,
I think we all look at ourselves and you
know,
you look at what's,
what's your eventual take on this?
Going to be like,
what is,
what's your body of work going to be
like after 20 years or 30 years and at
the end are you going to still be
enjoying this?
Like look at this brilliant guy.
Like what did he do wrong?
Like why,
why was he some of his shit so good.
Some of the shit that he wrote,
fear and loathing in Las Vegas is still
one of my favorite books just to just a
fucking mad crazy book.
You know,
this dude and his friend just dropping
acid.
And just fucking people over on the
hotel bills.
I mean,
it's a great fucking book.
It's just,
it just,
it's alive,
you know what I mean?
And
he's like his writing there some shit in
there that was alive and it's not
everybody can do that.
I don't know what it is or why a person
can or can't.
But what drives me crazy is when they
can do something like that and then they
still fall apart.
You know?
It's like,
it's almost like what brings them to the
dance kills them when they get there.
Yeah.
Well it's because nothing is constant.
You know,
like if you're so passionate about
something,
there's something that you need to
nurture in that or like.
And we're constantly changing.
Nothing is forever going to be that way.
So in five years from now,
like if you don't cultivate that kind of
life and everything,
you can,
all of a sudden five years down the
road,
just not give a fuck about land.
Just completely like be a completely
different,
which is fine.
We need to,
you have to get the,
you have to be comfortable in the
struggle.
And part of the struggle is constantly
creating,
constantly coming up with new things
because as soon as you stop doing that,
if you stopped creating and you stop
exploring it and the,
utilizing that part of your mind in
your,
you know,
whatever it is,
your spirit,
it goes away.
That's the only reason why it's there is
because it took you fucking 10,
15 years ago and on stage over and over
again until I cultivate this thing where
you know how to do it correctly,
like you get into this groove.
But that can easily slip away from you
just don't pay.
Like when I was on news radio,
there was like two years when I was on
where I didn't write a fucking single
joke.
I didn't do it.
All I did was performed at the laugh
factory.
And I performed at the comedy store.
And uh,
I didn't do any roadwork at all and I
didn't write it all.
I just,
I did the Sitcom.
A Sitcom was a lot of work.
It was,
you know,
we work long hours and I'd be tired and
I would show up at the comedy clubs.
And I just had no,
no ambition,
you know,
I didn't have any new material.
It was all the stuff that I'd been doing
for years already.
And I had lost all connection with what
I was saying,
you know what I mean?
Like some bits they get to a point where
you just kind of saying a bunch of
things that you know will work.
It's like I'm not even thinking about
this.
I'm not in the moment while I'm saying
And uh,
anyway,
um,
I,
I didn't realize it until I had some
writers come to see me,
some guys that were writers on news
radio.
It was ugly and it was a late night sat
at the comedy store and the late nights
at the comedy store in the main room.
And there's only like fucking 15 people
that places a vacuum.
Man,
it's a cavern.
And I went up there and just just really
had a shitty set.
It just felt uncomfortable and that made
me really realize like,
God,
you don't even work on your comedy
anymore.
Like,
what the fuck are you doing?
It's going to go away.
Like the thing that was the most fun for
you to do,
now you're not doing it anymore and now
when you do it,
you're like weird about it.
So maybe like sort of reorganize and
figure it out.
But I think for a lot of guys,
like they just start doing the,
they become successful or they somehow
or another,
you know,
get enough success so that they can make
a living.
And then they just kinda like stop,
you know,
that's when you kind of die on.
It's so sad.
And yet I feel myself,
I constantly have to keep.
I go,
you know,
can like it.
And I'm so new to this comedy game and
um,
I,
I find myself,
like when I was just in my little tiny
apartment in London,
I mean now it's still a tiny apartment,
Hollywood,
but you just change your surroundings
and the change the people around you.
And now all of a sudden it's a business
and you have an agent and a manager and
they have plans to career planning and
all of a sudden you're like,
Whoa,
whoa.
What's that?
What's that little spark that I had
inside me?
What was pushing me to do this in the
first place?
As soon as you lose that,
like you just like completely lost and
all of a sudden so easy to talk you into
being business minded and business
oriented too.
And I've talked to like comics that I
really like their interesting guy and
he'll start talking about like liquor
sales and shit and I'm like,
what are you even.
How do you even know that?
Like what are you,
why are you talking about this?
Have you ever thought about doing a song
about mountain dew though?
Roads.
Commercial.
When you're like,
as soon like online you have a
following.
Did you get approached by so many
people?
Well,
your videos have ridiculous numbers.
The every average everyday normal guy
just like,
was it 20 million?
Almost 21 million.
That's some serious numbers,
man.
You put ads on those and make money off
that shit.
Well they do like through a partnership
program at Youtube and they,
they'll put the little ads at the
bottom.
So they send you checks for that shit.
Yeah.
Make it a little bit of money on there.
Nothing spectacular.
No,
it's nothing.
I have to do other things and even to
pay my bills.
I heard that there's some dudes that
have like a kid's ones on there and
these,
these kids videos have such ridiculous,
like,
like very regular repeated customers.
And so the numbers are huge,
like $5 million and now these guys are
making like ridiculous money from
Youtube ads.
I've always heard that too,
but I've never really understood.
I thought it was a real commitment to
Dana White.
Really?
Yeah.
So it's real.
There are some kids who like I put out
videos and mine's more like content.
You allow sketches and songs and like I
created the content.
I'll shoot it,
edit it and put it out as like,
you know,
I don't have a TV show,
so this is me doing my own content and I
fucking love it.
And the creative freedom that comes
along with it.
No one's looking over your shoulder,
you're just doing whatever you want.
And I get,
I got to d,
that's my tip.
Oh,
it's amazing.
Like I'll never give that up.
You know,
I'll never,
it's also why your stuff is so good
because he is coming from your mind gets
all like when,
when,
when one person does this and it sounds
crazy,
but I really believed this.
When one person is involved in creating
something and then they put it out,
it's almost like you,
you,
you get a sense of their personality,
like you get like a glimpse into their
creative,
you know,
whatever the fuck of frequency.
They tune into what a bunch of people
get in it.
It can be really funny but might not
enjoy it as much as water down a little
bit more if that's real.
It sounds like totally like hippie
nonsense.
But I,
you know,
you,
it's why we appreciate people so much
when they do something and we enjoy it.
I mean think about what that's like to
like,
you know,
like whatever.
If it's a band,
some band that you fucking love,
like you got to hang out with Trent
reznor when you were a kid.
I mean,
what are you doing?
You're appreciating something.
This guy's producing and creating and
that's really what it's all about.
That's what being a fan is about.
Yeah,
trippy fucking thing.
Yeah.
No,
it's crazy.
I don't really even think about that.
Don't know how you get like I do the
shows and people.
Anyone just goes,
dude,
I love what you do.
I'm so like,
like taken.
Yeah,
and I'm so weird.
I'm very recent that recently in this,
but like I'm always like fucked.
So thankful.
I'm like,
dude,
like you know,
you're watching you enjoy it and loud.
Fuck.
It's just,
it's just a beautiful thing.
It's a great.
It's a great exchange.
Of course you got to deal with a bunch
of nuts.
You ever watched his video?
Highest fuck yeah.
Yeah,
I've seen that one too.
That's great.
We'll,
we'll play that one at the end.
Alright,
cool.
That's a teaser.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we'll let you know at the end.
We're going to have a song for you.
Anybody who's having a problem with this
podcast,
I'm getting it from itunes,
looking for the latest episodes every
time.
It's way easier.
If you just subscribe,
if you subscribe,
you get them as soon as we put it up
there,
but apparently apple has some weird new
way.
They're handling podcast now where it
doesn't allow you to ping the server.
This is all complicated shit,
but the long and short of it is the best
way to get the podcast.
The quickest is just subscribed on
itunes or you can always go to Joe
Rogan.net
and right after the podcast is over,
within a couple of hours,
Brian has a link up and you can,
you can download it from that.
So that's easy to.
So that's the way to do it.
Don dolby winding anymore.
And how does that work on your website?
Does it go?
Because I'm so technologically.
I,
yeah,
I've downloaded on itunes,
go straight to my library,
syncs with my ipod.
Like if I go onto your website,
does it go right into the itunes or drag
and drop or.
Well,
it's just a file to download the MP
three and MP three file and it's always
because I want it to be available not
just for Itunes,
you know I wanted on Zune and you've got
some wonky old MP,
three recorder,
one of them little USB jammies.
It doesn't even have like A.
Yeah,
if you're.
If you're in the Zune marketplaces,
hold down your power button,
wait for it to reset,
and then I realized shit
making jokes.
Is that a Microsoft joke?
Darkly with.
We'll try to sneak in Microsoft joking
you both the device.
The device was no good.
Hey Verizon,
you can't.
What's up with this new iphone?
Has a world chip in it,
but you don't.
You don't turn it on.
You fucking Weirdos.
You're scared.
Your network's gonna Crumble,
bitches.
That's what it is.
They've been talking so much shit on 18
and t they don't understand the power of
the iphone.
When that motherfucker comes,
a wave of freaks,
they're going to come over to your side.
It's going to be like 15 percent of the
people from 18 t they're estimating are
gonna vacate their contracts early.
That's a large number of men,
even more like business people.
You know what I was doing an AP and t
commercial last night I was sitting
there and I was sending all these photos
to my flicker and I was also trying to
download this youtube video and then
somebody calls me if somebody would have
called me during that on the verizon
network,
all that shit would have failed your
right.
And so I was thinking that's pretty big
for me.
I'm a heavy user of Internet.
Yeah.
But I mean even if you're on twitter and
you're loading of video and then
somebody calls you halfway through it,
guess what?
That video is not loading.
That's right.
Yeah.
That's a good plug.
That.
That's a good point if you look at it
that way.
No.
Yeah.
Well I don't understand why verizon
can't do that.
I,
from what I understand though,
when they get to four G,
that won't be an issue anymore.
Is that correct?
Yeah.
Four.
So for ge,
even though it's cdma as opposed to just
the network's good,
but it's actually just older,
like an older older technology.
It's called CDMA and if for some reason,
even though it's older technology,
it penetrates deeper into buildings.
Yeah,
I guess that's one of the that goes so
it gives you more cancer kids.
You better cancer,
but I've got a new top,
new,
a title to my book.
It's called if you get cancer from your
cell phone,
you're a fucking pussy.
I know what you really wanted to say,
but pussies.
They're retired word.
No,
no,
no.
It'd be more.
You're a pussy and FFA.
Gigi.
Word.
Otee word.
You know what though?
I mean,
has anyone done research like on ball
cancer?
Is Ball cancer up right now because
you're a fucking cell phones by your
balls 90 percent of the time.
I don't know what the fuck you're doing
with your phone ma'am.
Don't stick it on your ball pocket.
That's like being on the side of your
head.
Right?
So it's pretty close to your boss about
the having a laptop on your.
On your lap,
just so close to books,
balls and all your shit.
I can imagine some kind of.
You know the laptop though.
It's heat.
The battery,
I use that for it as a form of birth
control.
Right.
Kill your boss.
I did it on purpose.
Torture.
Those little faggots.
Whoops.
Oh,
trick trick.
Trick me to put it in my head.
I'm you.
That word in Canada there.
Well,
it shouldn't be an American either.
It's not.
That shouldn't be said to.
Shouldn't be award that has all this
power.
Especially a good juicy one.
Jamie Kilstein told me he retired it
recently to really,
every time you accidentally say it,
you should do something like you have to
buy an Elton John cd or you have to.
You have to watch one episode of Ellen
Full George Michael Video.
You have to give something back.
I love that freedom song,
man.
Remember that time we sang it on the
podcast.
That's a great God damn thing in the hot
tub.
No,
I blocked that out bro.
Shut up bro.
What the fuck are you touring?
Do you,
uh,
do you do?
Uh,
yeah.
I mean I've been trying to quite a bit
for the past two years.
I took a little break because one is
write some stuff and do some more the
internet stuff,
but when you do it,
you do it.
I'm like,
go out for a weekend.
Come back.
I started doing that.
I have minneapolis so bad.
It's so.
I don't even know my dates,
but I'd like to have some Minneapolis in
like march or what is the website?
Yeah.
Uh,
yeah.
Let's check out the website.
Michael Keaton's on.
Yeah,
that's John Lewis.
Schwab.com
and spelled that motherfucker.
Yeah.
Good luck.
J O n l e j o I eat or just go to
youtube.
Google like data and just search.
Sorry.
Go ahead.
Have you ever thought about just
changing your last name?
Like John La,
la or something?
Johnny La.
Kevin James had to do that.
His last name was sniffing those.
Really?
Yeah.
It was really tricky.
And Him,
his brother Gary and Gary picked
Valentine and Kevin Pick pick james
because it was the name of his old Kung
Fu instructor.
My last name is not red band because my
last name,
bright red bird right from the movie
trailers.
When you see a movie,
other advantage.
I used to be a projectionist most of my
life.
Okay,
okay.
I like it.
I like.
His videos were really good.
I got to figure out how to make money
with it.
Anybody out there with a suggestion?
You do yourself freaks because I don't
know you stars Porn Stars.
Porn stars is the way to go and make
comedy.
Comedy Porn.
Yeah.
Making money on the Internet.
That's what Brian Needs.
Brian needs more porn stars of his life
for sure.
I know.
How do you get into the porn circle?
Oh,
he's deep.
Really?
He went into a podcast.
Is that all it takes?
My house.
We'll have a podcast and that you can
interview this morning.
Star deep.
Get deep in the crate.
You write all your stuff yourself and
like,
do you just sit there and think of a
good idea?
And I mean,
did you start off doing like,
like just you using a cell phone camera?
They playing around what it was was like
I was uh,
I,
I went to theater school in Montreal.
Then I graduated and I got a roll on
this French language TV show,
which it was,
you know,
it's cool.
It's great.
I appreciate it.
Great job and everything,
but it wasn't really what I want to do.
By the way,
how much does it help with chicks being
bilingual and the other languages?
French sally field.
You must seem so sophisticated.
Especially if you know something about
wine,
that's all you need.
I mean so many.
Growing them so quickly.
You can know nothing about wine.
Oh,
you'd have to do is just start talking
about the area of France where these
grapes are grown and that bitch she.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
no,
it uh,
it helps a little bit but it's weird to
Montreal,
like if you don't like it being an
English dude in Montreal and on a
friend's show like chicks like me
because I had the English,
the English or the French chicks like
you because he's spoken with as well.
And then out here it's Kinda like,
Oh really?
Yeah,
the French thing.
Skill.
I thought you guys didn't like French
people,
wasn't all that freedom fry French
Montreal is okay.
France,
France is a different animal,
those guys,
we don't even like French fries.
And you're more freedom.
So you were on the show.
So you're on this,
uh,
French speaking show and you speak
fluent French as well as English.
Not as well as English is.
My Dad's French.
Canadian.
So is there a different,
like when you're sending the language,
is structured different comedy
structured different when you do it?
Yeah,
I find comedy in French.
It's a completely different beast.
It's like you have a bunch in Montreal,
Montreal,
when they do the just for laughs
festival,
they'll have all these like guy speaking
in France.
It's really weird and it's super like
superstars,
French Canada,
huge that people have never heard of.
Yeah.
Just to give you an example,
there are 7 million or 8 million people
in Quebec.
The show that I was on had one point 2
million people watching it every week.
Like on the league,
that's what we get,
but that's broadcast all
over the United States.
Like they're very supportive of their
culture and they,
they consume a quebecois culture and
they have like huge comedy star.
It's like a little,
that's why they kinda like why their own
country is like a little country on its
own.
On the French side.
English side is just is like,
like English Canada anywhere else.
Quebec is a very strange area in and of
itself that they want to separate from
the rest of Canada.
It's like a constant issue.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
What's that about?
Uh,
well I mean it's goes way back but it's
basically,
you know,
new France became kinda like the,
the English beat,
the French and then like you had all
this huge French population and now was
English territory and they were kind of
of like lax enough to go,
okay,
I can keep practicing your Catholicism
and your things,
love,
we'll let you alone,
but you're,
you know,
this is the British empire know.
But they kind of flourished as a culture
and they stayed pretty close together.
And like now,
Quebec is predominantly French speaking
and it's a culture that's just kind of
kept going throughout the years and now
they want to protect the culture and
there are many of the laws in Canada
that do protect the culture,
like Kinda like signs have to be more
French than with a larger in French than
in English.
Like a lot of things like that that are
very controversial,
um,
equal rights.
Right?
Well,
it's just that you have to have that.
It has to be in French at all.
Like you can go to Chinatown,
there's some shit that has nothing in
English on it,
so that's fine.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
I don't feel well that's ridiculous.
No,
I know it's very controversial,
but there are many things that they're
trying to protect because the fear is
basically that 100 years down the road,
uh,
there were French culture.
But I mean,
you know,
things change.
What are we going to do once we start
reading minds and we can travel through
time.
We're still going to have to talk
French.
You fuck.
No.
Is it that important?
Goddammit,
you're slowing down evolution county.
The language dies.
It dies,
man.
Fuck it isn't what you mean.
Is that what it's supposed to be
important,
right?
Your intent not what?
Fuck,
Blah Blah.
The way you fucking say it.
Let's do it.
Which is neutral.
You know,
it just expresses they don't want their
language to evolve.
If it,
if it gets absorbed,
it gets involved.
That's what happened.
Sorry,
that doesn't mean it's bad.
No,
I have not.
Right Brian.
Goddamn.
I made out like I'm going to get shit
for this a little bit so I'll do the
French.
I'll just go.
I'm not going to know because I know how
important it is.
Especially like artists on the French
and I've worked with quite a bit like on
that TV show.
They're,
most of them are sovereigns are
separate.
This.
Yeah.
No,
I guess they probably know they wouldn't
survive if the full country to hear
them.
You want to stay in one area and only
speak French.
I'm,
I'm gonna.
I'm gonna stay neutral on competitive
motherfuckers topics and I love Montreal
and I love French Canada.
Don't know what I'm saying.
I'm as a human being,
as a human being,
I don't.
I don't like an attached to anything.
Yeah,
especially getting attached to the way
you say things.
A certain lands.
Who gives a fuck and everybody's like.
Someone said that to me,
man.
You don't have to care for man fucking
English.
Going to be a second language and
everybody's going to speak Spanish
first.
I go,
well then I'll learn Spanish and fucking
dummy and guess what?
Stupid.
It's not.
It's not going to happen within my
lifetime.
And if I grew up learning Spanish
instead of English,
does that really make a difference?
God dammit.
Of course it doesn't.
You fucking stooge it's what you're
thinking is what's important.
It's not what language you think it and
that's dumb.
It's better if we all have one language.
Let's get rid of.
I mean we got rid of Latin.
Okay,
can we get rid of Chinese?
What's do this?
Kick that shit out.
You guys know what to say.
English things.
Come on.
Get rid of it.
The ultimate of a president got into
office.
It's like,
first of all,
everybody's got to fucking learn
English.
Done right.
You want to really communicate.
It's real simple.
Okay,
we'll learn English.
We won't bomb you.
You learn English.
Is that a deal?
The fuck.
Is it so hard?
No secret languages.
Kill all your other languages because I
don't want you to be saying some shit
that I don't understand.
The new president when I was 17,
I was on spring break and this is
probably the problem is there's fucking
a lot of dudes that are listening to
that going,
well,
fuck you,
man.
He's going to fuck.
Good point.
We do have all the bombs.
Fuck all those Brown queers.
Queers in Quebec so you can French all
over the world.
All of them.
Anyone fucking even English if the
Spanish.
When I'm on the Spanish side,
I'm whoever's winning.
I'm with evolution.
God dammit.
Oh yeah.
Mexico comes over and takes over
America.
Well,
I guess we have made cocaine legal.
You fuck like what you did.
Stupid fucking Mexican gangsters take
over the country.
They realized how soft we are.
We're creating a whole nation of savage
killers down there.
You know,
you've seen those video footages from
live leak with a 12 year old hitman or
fucking torturing people before they
tell them Yo.
I mean,
that's right there.
You can derive their.
This is nuts.
The fact that we're not dealing with
that.
We shouldn't even fucking Afghanistan.
It takes me 12 hours to get there on a
plane who shouldn't be beer right next
door where everyone's crazy,
where they're cutting people's fucking
heads off and selling coke.
God Damn Mother fuckers on Hollywood
fucking boulevard.
The Mexicans,
Mexicans are mad at me.
The French Canadians are mad at me.
I'm trying to piss off everybody already
know.
Everyone saw verizon.
French Canadian know.
I love you.
I love you and I love your poutine.
I love the comedy works in Montreal.
That little club I didn't last time.
It was a bunch of fucking great man.
Well,
you know,
Montreal always confused me because I
lived in Boston and I had this cold
weather douchebag theory.
I was like,
well,
the reason why Boston people are so
douchey is because it's cold as fuck up
there and get you get angry like six
months out a year,
you know,
mass holes we call them and you know.
But I was like,
but wait a minute,
I go up to Montreal,
it's three hours north or more,
right?
More drivings and like four hours,
no,
four hours for four fucking hours in a
car north of Boston.
And the people are cool as fuck and it's
like a European city.
It's more sophisticated.
It's like the culture is totally
different.
The women are so much nicer,
you know?
It's weird,
man.
It's a weird,
weird thing.
But also we're very polite so we hide
that shit.
Like you guys are just like fuck you.
And we're like,
fuck this guy.
Yeah.
But fuck,
this guy's way nicer to be around.
I keep it together.
Shithead.
No.
Yeah,
I know you guys like Boston,
like everyone from 18 to 20.
Everyone's always up in Montreal.
Just partying because like you guys
still have.
I still don't understand 21 to drink.
It's good.
It's good because it makes it harder for
people to get into bars.
It shouldn't be in bars and it's good
because they don't know how to not drink
and drive yet.
That's the scariest shit.
Just got the license.
The as shit to me is kids that don't
know how to drive and they're drinking,
you know?
I've seen.
I've seen stupid shit man.
I've seen people rear end people and
I've seen many things.
I,
I think it's a good thing.
I think they shouldn't be able to drive
for their 21.
I shouldn't have been able to drive,
but the problem is you have to work so
you gotta let them drive it.
Eighteen or 17 or whatever the fuck it
is,
but I saw some fucking kid down the
street the other day in his mom's Lexis,
like it was a big lexus truck and suv.
He couldn't have been more than 15,
16 years old.
This kid was fucking riding my ass and
weaving through traffic and cutting
lanes off and going way over the speed
limit.
I'm like,
kid,
you don't know how to drive.
Yeah.
You're like,
you're taking a big chance with a large
vehicle that doesn't stop well,
it doesn't turn well at all,
or giant trucks and this fucking kid is
driving like he's doing formula one
racing.
Scary Shit.
Speed.
He got away with it.
I mean he got home,
he didn't die,
but something could have happened
easily.
Someone could have fucked up.
Someone could have ran off a curb so you
know,
he could have had to make a split second
move and it would have been around what
you think about it.
15,
16 years old.
Like I was retarded.
Retarded.
Totally like an idiot.
And to be in,
to be behind the wheel controlling is
huge.
Hunk of metal around thousands of
people.
Yeah.
I don't think that's a good idea.
It's funny.
This has been a topic of conversation
recently.
Even though my message board about
people that were like 21,
I was saying that when I was 20 I was
retarded.
Like you know,
don't,
don't tell me what the fuck is going on
when you're 20.
I don't want to hear you talk about,
you know,
what's wrong with the world when you're
20 and a lot of people are going back in
the fucking Middle Ages,
you know,
20 was middle aged like you know,
we could try and don't discount my
opinion because I'm 20 years old.
I totally agree with you.
You have 10 kids and have you killed
people playing world of warcraft,
your mom's basement.
You're not the same 20 year old and it's
not to undervalue Europe.
Your opinion or your observations.
You might be very intelligent.
You might have some observations that
are very valid.
Is Not saying that.
It's just say the fact that you're even
confident enough to want people to
listen to your opinion at 20 shows me,
you're on the wrong road to stop being
cocky.
You should be like just asking questions
and looking around.
Just jumping in and,
and,
and trying to force your opinions on.
When you're 20,
you don't really know
that much.
It might have some information,
but man,
you look back and how when you were
like,
when you were 20,
there's no 20 year old that is going to
be able to stand on television with a
microphone and tell the world what needs
to be fixed.
You know,
just fucking stopped dude.
It's a developmental cycle or you're
very confident.
You're very intelligent.
Congratulations.
Yeah,
but don't get ahead of yourself.
Of course.
You know,
when I was 20 I was fucking dumb,
but I thought it was smart and I was
right about a lot of things.
You know?
I had a good,
good point of view,
but it was still,
you're just fucking spastic.
You're just like that 15 year old kid
driving that truck.
You don't know what the fuck you're
doing.
You're slamming into walls and shit.
You don't know how to use the brakes.
I have once in a while I have to check
in with early twenties John.
I mean it's morally like,
so like,
oh this I'm reading like I still am very
curious.
I love reading,
but at early twenties like I thought
like I figured it out like my moral code
and I was so like,
what was the code?
We didn't know.
I was very much a,
a Vegan for.
Oh really?
Yeah,
but that I know,
I know,
but that took me a little while to go.
Oh,
okay.
No,
because I was reading a lot,
like I'm trying to figure out what is a
right decision was wrong and figuring it
out.
Sure.
And that was now like a totally
different,
completely different person.
But in my early twenties,
like everything was an important moral
decision and I have very,
like,
my parents are like really pentecostal,
like really religious,
very like good people,
but you know,
very religious people.
So I kind of have that baggage where I'm
like I'm trying to,
you know,
doing good is like what makes my parents
proud and as opposed to like oh I have
all these fans and stuff.
Like if I do something like really nice
or something like that,
that's when my parents are really proud
of me.
So like,
I kind of have this thing,
so I was trying to figure like him and
now you know,
you know,
and I'm 30 and living in La and you
know,
like I've have a bit of success and so
once in a while I have to go,
okay,
early twenties John,
am I being an asshole right now and am I
being a good person?
What do you think?
And a lot of the time he's like,
fuck you asshole.
Don't talk to me.
Well what's early twenties John?
A radical though,
was he?
No,
no,
no.
I'm still very close to who I was but I
was much more like,
I guess rigid about things.
So like there's more like,
I dunno,
like I went to a certain,
like the super,
I still don't,
I when I'm shopping,
like I tried it give my money were like,
it's because buying is voting but back
it's like,
really,
it's that early when you're figuring
shit out,
you're like,
I just read this book.
And Naomi Klein's uh,
you know,
whenever the fuck it was called.
And I'm like,
okay,
I get it.
I don't know,
you know,
you try to like be,
I don't know,
it's everything's kind of black and
white.
When you realize you get older,
you're like,
oh,
it's just all gray and you try to figure
it out.
You try to be a good person as much as
you can and try to approach things with
love and all that kind of stuff.
It's very tricky.
You know the eating of animals thing,
is it really a very controversial
subject and I know a lot of people that
have a lot of different opinions on it
and they're all very,
very like adamant about how they are.
Like the people who eat meat
just really want to justify it and they
get super aggressive about it and you
know,
the people that don't,
they.
I mean I've had some annoying
motherfuckers on my message board.
They want to talk to me about eating
animals,
like don't do it.
Just try it and then go on and on and
on.
Just trying to shove it in your throat
like God damn you annoying fucking
socially retarded dunce.
Whatever you're doing is going to make
me not want to do it.
Do you not get that?
When people like say an annoying shit
like that and like make a mistake,
you know,
think of Karma kicking you in the Dick.
Stupid.
Get Away,
get away with your nonsense.
Those beans are alive.
You fuck.
Okay.
Those beans are eating.
They're screaming as you bite down on
it,
you boil them,
they're dying in there.
They're rotting and boiling water that
led us screams and agony as you rip it
from its fucking mother.
Fuck you.
That's life too stupid.
It's like,
why is,
why is animal life more important than
plant life?
Because we're semi related,
you know,
but that,
that's fucking stupid because you step
on bugs all the time.
We're convenient.
Shitheads.
All right.
And the funny,
the most,
uh,
the funniest thing is that eating meat
and animal proteins helped us develop
like our and come to the point in our
consciousness that where we are because
it helped develop the brain rapidly,
which is the fall.
That's actually a controversial theory.
Yeah.
Because it doesn't work that way with
the other predators.
I mean Jaguars when have big brands and
by the way,
but that was a theory that theory,
I believe was formulated before they
realize how many monkeys chimpanzees
eat.
No,
they didn't realize how,
how fucking ruthless and violent chimps
really were until they started doing
some studies.
I forget the,
the,
the um,
the guy's name who ran the show.
It was like a BBC show,
but he was the first one to get footage
of chimps eating monkeys.
And I think that was in the nineties.
So I think these ideas that they had
about that,
there was this too.
There's two other theories.
One of them is a throwing arm and that
when people develop the ability to throw
things,
that,
that sort of kicked off our evolution
because we started killing things that
were far,
far away from us.
Then we started getting better at
hunting.
We thrive.
Then as we thrive,
we got a little bit more confidence and
we started thinking about things more.
It's like that the more calm you can
get,
the more control of your environment,
the more you have free time to think
about shit because you're not always
fighting off Jaguars and all these
different things.
So we figured out how to do things like
throw spears,
throw rocks,
you know?
That's one theory.
That's another theory.
The other one is psychedelics.
The other one is psychedelic mushrooms
and that's the most controversial one,
but really the most fascinating one,
and it's a terence Mckenna stoned ape
theory and this theory is that somewhere
along the line,
and this is the undisputable facts,
somewhere along the line,
the human brain size doubled over a
period of 2 million years and that is in
the entire fossil record,
the most confusing thing,
like more than anything,
like they're like,
well,
how does this happen?
Like it's weird for any Oregon to grow
double the size,
but the most spectacular Oregon as far
as creating things on the planet is in
no question the brain,
the human is when we alter our
environment,
we create nuclear bombs beyond beyond a
doubt.
It all happens supposedly inside this
area and this area doubled in two years.
Well,
it's coincidentally also the same time
that the,
uh,
the rain forest receded into grasslands.
There was a climate change and Terence
Mckenna's theory is that monkeys were
forced or lower primates were forced to
come out of the trees and experiment
with new foods sources because the rain
forest were gone and these animals that
were in this once lush tropical
environment had to adapt to this new
environment.
And one of the things they did was there
was a lot of cows that were eating the
grass and they would flip over counters
looking for bugs.
And that's the best place for cubensis
mushrooms to grow.
So these cubensis mushrooms would grow
in this cow shit.
And these,
these chips and those,
whatever the fuck they were,
you know,
lower primates Australia pivot gets
wherever the fuck it was.
They would eat these mushrooms.
And the idea is twofold.
One that there was a,
a direct increase in their ability to
see things because when you eat suicide,
and especially in low doses,
it increases your visual acuity.
And the other thing was that it would
give them this sort of community like
loving atmosphere,
protecting atmosphere and that will also
aid and they're less conflicts.
The less conflicts that they had would
aid in their innovation,
you know,
just like with the other thing.
And also they would start having
psychedelic experiences and in large
doses these psychedelic experiences
would slowly help them evolve much,
much quicker and sort of figure things
out that they may be not a figured out.
And the idea of the really weird part of
the idea is that they think this is all
Mckenna and a few other psychos.
They think that what mushrooms are,
is some sort of an alien intelligence
that it's come here from an asteroid.
Because the reason for that is there's
no,
like there's nothing that can survive in
a vacuum better than spores.
And we know that a bunch of shit is come
here on asteroids from other planets
like Dna or excuse me,
I'm like,
uh,
amino acids are the building blocks for
life and water.
Water comes on comets and asteroids.
And we know that spores can survive in a
vacuum.
And the idea is that somewhere on some
other planet there was some type of a
spore and it came here on an asteroid
landed and the way it communicates with
people as you eat it,
this is what caused human beings to
evolve at a monkey's.
I mean,
it is one of those five bong hit stare
at space and think it through for like
10 hours.
At first.
It sounds totally ridiculous that
mushrooms,
mushrooms are silly,
like you know,
if he's one scientist or whatever,
that that thinks that there's scientists
really.
I mean he was,
he was a scholar.
I mean,
I don't know what it was.
The ethno botanists I think was his
chosen.
If you ask any of the other thousands of
scientists that would know that anything
close to what he's talking about when
they think are very,
very high,
you have to realize that as a scientist,
first all getting
behind anything that advocates a
completely new direction in evolution
and one based on psychedelic mushrooms,
illegal drugs,
that's a tough fucking sell.
So most scientists would never choose
that as a point of study.
It's a virtual cycle.
No,
come on,
could be that,
it could be that too,
but it's also they discount the idea
that mushrooms could be some sort of
potential human evolution tool.
They discount that because it sounds
ridiculous that an illegal drug could
potentially aid in your evolution and
most of them are ignorant of the
experience itself.
I mean maybe some of them are fucked
around with it had a little bit,
but to have a real full blown
psychedelic experience,
I guarantee you you wouldn't discredit
it.
So what are these monkeys?
Instead of like taking the cow turds,
they were like,
they took one bite with like it says
gross and they told their friends food
come on and they eat bugs.
Eat ever go.
That's dumb.
Because they don't have observed the
mushrooms.
This whole theory does make it makes no
sense.
Right?
Right.
But they do what they've observed the
meeting mushrooms.
So observe other long time ago,
but no on monkeys now he,
you know,
a lot of animals like target psychedelic
substances like rain,
beard,
target,
the Amanita mushrooms in Siberia.
It's,
they're famous for it.
They like knock people over to get the
mushrooms.
They fucking love them.
I dog used to knock shit over to get to
my.
We'd really,
really like little buckets and he'd just
go and I come back and he'd be acting
all weird and look in the ash tray.
It's just like all empty and like,
no,
it's this,
this subject is a very controversial one
because whenever you,
um,
the,
a lot of people have a very strong
opinion against this idea and they're
just like,
that's ridiculous.
That doesn't make sense.
You know,
mushrooms,
like,
think about what the fuck mushrooms do
do to you if you've done it,
if you've ever done it,
you know what they do.
It's fucking crazy.
Beyond description,
your whole world changes.
Everything around you becomes
interlocking geometric patterns that you
can see through to infinity.
Just that experience itself.
What the fuck is happening?
Why is it so powerful and why it's so
you Nana mostly positive do that to your
mind what's going on?
And if it is an agent of evolution,
right,
are you know,
but you're not being poisoned that the
ld 50 rate for siliciden mushrooms is
like fucking 50 pounds or something.
That's like what you have to eat to kill
half the people.
It's ridiculous.
It's like you can't die from it.
We were talking about like hundreds of
times more than the effective dose it
would take to kill you.
You'd have to be a total idiot to die
for mushrooms.
Right?
I mean there's a lot in you just
probably throw up.
Anyway.
There were some.
I don't think anybody's ever died unless
there's some toxic mold that was on it,
which is very common in my short.
Not only that mushrooms that look like
psilocybin mushrooms,
but there's some other fucking one that
completely jacks your system.
But that's the problem with anything.
Like you could say.
Again,
there's no mold on these mushrooms.
You're not going to die and there could
be mold on this.
What you're supposed to be buying or not
buying,
supposed to be eating and
run out of the ground are supposed to be
legal.
I know this is all subject of what we're
doing to like food.
We don't let anybody grow their own
mushrooms.
We in.
It's fucking really hard to get to so
you don't know who's handling it and how
the guys growing it to yourself,
it was legal.
You can have any God damned backyard or
in your basement.
You could grow a whole shelf of
mushrooms.
It's easiest.
Fuck a dude who had like Scott Mushrooms
out here like I had back home.
He said,
have a reliable source where it didn't
kill me and it was awesome,
but I just,
I just so weird when it's not controlled
your life.
Not only that,
it's selling who's selling something
illegal and that that's where it gets
tricky.
You know,
the real problem with illegal drugs is
you got to talk to people to get them.
You know,
that's the deal with some dude and he
wants to sell you mushrooms.
Come on,
man.
Who is this guy?
You're selling mushrooms.
Where are you at in your life?
You know,
how crazy are you?
You know you weren't a wire.
Get the fuck over here.
You know,
you know,
it's like,
that's the problem.
It should,
you shouldn't have to deal with some
person is willing to break the law.
It would,
would,
it should be,
is there's no fucking law.
And by the way,
there's a lot of cool people sell
mushrooms.
Don't get me wrong,
I'm just teasing,
but what I'm saying is valid in a lot of
cases,
man.
I remember the guy we used to deal with,
this dude named Jake the snake.
That's how you get weed for,
uh,
before I got a medical card,
this motherfucker was so annoying.
He was so annoying that Eddie Bravo had
a choke him out like three times and
couldn't believe that Eddie could choke
them out.
He's like,
man,
it was a real fight,
dude.
I kick your ass.
And so Eddie's like,
come on man,
you act like an asshole.
And the guy's like,
I'm telling you man,
that shit ain't gonna work on me.
And I was like,
okay,
let's,
let's go out in the yard and let's say
it takes him down straggles and puts him
to sleep.
Wakes him up.
Who?
This happened,
man,
I didn't fucking happen.
That's bullshit.
You got lucky.
So they do it again.
Let's go again.
He takes him down,
chokes him out,
puts them to sleep like you fucking
dummy.
That's a black belt in Brazilian
Jujitsu.
Like really?
You think you could just,
just,
you're just tough enough to fight that
shit off.
And this is where we used to get our
weed from.
It was so annoying.
This guy was so dumb.
He was like a dude who's half his head
was made of cardboard.
It was just like there's something in
there that's dulling your electrical
circuits.
His wet cardboard leaking on the
circuitry is whole fucking thing is
shorting out.
It was just dumb.
Motherfucker sold weed.
Yeah,
that was his name.
Uh,
the uh,
the monkey thing possible,
man.
Wait harder for me to go.
I believe in something then for me to
dis not whoa,
fuck.
I just lost it.
I know what you're saying.
But like,
yeah,
I remained open.
Like just the fuck that we're we,
we used to be like bacteria on this rock
and now we're sitting here talking with
headphones about shit on computers.
Like,
yeah,
that's fucking weird.
They go,
oh,
maybe that happened.
Yeah,
maybe it happened.
Like I'm not going to disbelief,
but for me to go for sure that this
thing that's harder to fix my point.
Exactly.
Love that.
You just said that.
I always say the exact same thing when
it comes to like Ufo and stuff and I'm
like,
why do you want to
believe?
Do you have personal experience with a
Ufo?
You've been taking a board.
How do you not know that all these
people are crazy?
Because I know a lot of crazy people,
man.
People are full of Shit.
They lie a lot.
You have to always keep that.
Brian always says it best.
You always got to keep what you say.
You've always got to keep all doors
open.
So what do you say?
We were talking about this once before
when it was about Ufos.
Oh,
keep everything on the table.
I'll give you ever yet.
Not Everything on the table.
Don't just commit to one thing or the
other man said when you were speaking
about life and,
and this is,
I mean,
think about this is the nuttiest fucking
shit ever.
There's a new study that they found it
and that life today resembles life of a
billion years ago,
or cancer today.
Rather,
it resembles life of a billion years
ago.
That I'm going to try to find the.
It's very scary because what it implies
is that,
you know,
what we came out of,
we came out of here,
this right here.
Here's the article.
Life resemble a cancer cells resembled
life 1 billion years ago,
and they have all these,
uh,
these comparisons.
And you know,
this all,
like some serious scientific study about
the origins of life and the origins of
cancer.
And the idea,
and this is where it could be completely
insane,
but the idea is if human life becomes so
fucked up and chaotic and so unnatural
and so polluted by chemicals and
destroyed by ideology and nonsense,
and we just breed ourselves down to
mush.
This is the mush.
What this is is this is what started
life in the first place.
Life was just a series of fucking cells
that grew out of control and became
eventually human beings and for this
shit to be growing inside of us at an
ever expanding rate constantly is like
the primordial ooze trying to reclaim
its creation.
This is the universal fucking extra
sketch and they're shaking it right now.
Wrap your fucking head around that man.
That's what cancer is,
man.
What cancer is is absolute proof
positive that this is the wrong path and
the universe is slowly swallowing the
human race.
Back up,
wrap your shit around that homey.
That's the universe is know as art.
Fuck man.
You know,
and we don't,
we don't look at it that way.
I mean we're obviously just learning
this,
but we don't look at it as being
something that could be reversed that
quickly.
But look at like,
you know,
they're talking about like cancer of
like,
like the $10,000
100,000
years ago.
The people didn't get cancer,
they didn't get cancer.
And there's a lot of scientists that
believe that all cancer is within the
industrial age and previously before
that,
any exposure to chemicals and things
that Cortina just shit,
but this shit doesn't really exist in
nature.
And when you're eating a,
like a,
a primate or um,
what,
what would you call it?
A Paleo Diet,
you know,
evolve vegetables and all,
uh,
you know,
clean animals that you kill,
like you're not getting introduced to
any of the shit that creates cancer.
And I don't know if that's right or no.
I mean,
I don't know how the fuck they could
ever prove it.
Yeah.
They would have to go back in time,
you know,
whatever.
1,000
years or whatever the fuck it was before
people ever figured out how to fuck with
chemicals.
What is at 10,000
years ago.
Not even,
probably only a couple chemicals.
I mean,
when was the first cancer?
When was the first cancer ever recorded?
Fuck this.
It's a really interesting thing,
man,
because let's say let's just get crazy
and let's give it a few thousand years.
Let's say the first cancer started like
2000 years ago.
Okay.
If that is the case,
we think about what a short period of
time that is 2000 years to tonight to
today and you compare how much more
people have cancer now and how many more
people are around now than before in
constantly we're working on a cure for.
We're going to figure it out.
It's like,
Whoa,
what is this?
Yeah,
what the fuck is cancer life?
It's life growing out of control and the
way to get this is the crazy thing about
life growing out of control and cancer,
the way they kill it is it's fucking
poison the shit out of you.
They poisoned the shit out of you and
they hope that this,
this thing dies before the host does.
That's what chemotherapy is.
That's terrifying.
That's a terrifying notion.
It's like you have a parasite inside you
and we're going to slowly bring you to
death's door and hopefully it'll kill
the parasite.
And then you get to like start eating
oatmeal again and walking without a
limp.
And then as soon as that happens,
get.
Oh,
your friend is back for another fucking
round,
grabs a hold of you,
tried to choke you and drag you to the
ground.
Brother had,
uh,
Hodgkin's roommate is like a 14 years
old.
Oh my God.
I had lumps and stuff.
We want to see a doctor first.
Dr Wentz.
See like,
Hey,
you're working out.
It's normal something your glands or
whatever.
Okay.
Go to a second doctor.
I know you have cancer.
Like I know he did it.
A chemotherapy and everything is fine
and you know where the lumps like a
dude,
he had like this huge lump right here.
Like,
yes.
Joey Dexter had the dude name Philip.
Michael.
Michael Hall in the eighties movies.
Um,
so yeah,
it's a really common thing,
right?
Yeah.
What is it?
What do they think it's cross from?
They have any idea?
Is it genetic?
Because idea,
man.
And at the same time we grew up like,
we're just like eating,
like I'm a big family,
they brothers and sisters,
so we'd like we'd eat hot dogs and
hamburger helper and,
and just,
you never know where it can come from
anywhere.
It can be genetic and like all that
stuff.
Uh,
my,
my aunt died of the same thing when she
was 24 like way back when she was young.
So it's somewhat in the genetics,
but at the same time,
you never know.
May Not even like,
I'm like,
I do go to a doctor like twice a year or
no,
I don't go to the doctor probably for
that reason.
I probably should.
Wow.
That's terrifying.
Yeah.
No,
it is really,
really healthy.
Yeah,
I will.
Well,
I know a dude who eats really brown.
He's got cancer right now.
Oh,
just,
he's.
He's got really pale skin and he's
always out in the sun.
Apparently it got some skin cancer and
cancer and eats terrible.
It's all mashed potatoes and fucking
meatloaf and you know,
no vitamins.
So homeboys got to start eating like
serious,
heavy green diet.
Very leafy,
thick,
green vegetables.
Whenever I do that man and I got really
heavily
into like eating salads,
like big salads every day.
Really feel way better.
It's really amazing.
It's like,
yeah,
most of our food is so fucking like
dead.
You know,
like you can get something.
There's something out of eating plants
and eating live things,
you know,
you really do get something from it.
But the thing is you've gotta get you
gotTa,
get fresh,
organic like in Montreal,
like I just went back there last week.
It's snow storm,
like nothing fresh is growing there.
So everything's important from all
around the world sprayed with Kent if
you're not getting organic and fresh
like the shit's been in a freezer,
sitting in chemicals,
get a wash your lettuce.
My brother worked at uh,
a fruit and vegetable place.
He said they used to take the celery
out.
You have to wear gloves when you like.
They'd unloaded from the boxes and put
it in the front because he'd get burns
on his hands from the chemicals that
were on the celery.
I think about that shit.
You're putting that in your body man.
And how long do you have to wash the
salary for that shit to get?
How long would it take before you
started getting burns?
Oh,
he said like you write like you learn
right away,
like it,
you handle it a bit and it's just the
chemicals,
especially on celery for some reason.
Fuck,
I love salary,
man.
I made celery juice all the time.
Yeah.
Well if you get then once again organic
too,
but still.
Yeah,
I've heard a lot of organic is bullshit
to label it as organic and it's not
really organic.
What does organic stand for?
I mean,
what is it?
What is the actual definition of
organic?
Does it mean no chemicals?
No pesticides.
No genetically modified.
I think that's what it's supposed to
mean.
Boast to me then.
But as we know,
you watch those documentaries like food
inc,
like it's just the,
uh,
the genetically modified.
This shit's like flies all over.
That's nuts.
Yeah.
Well,
that's what's really crazy about
genetically modified crops is how they
affect other farmers have gotten sued
because the shit flew through the air
and landed on their fields and they
found there these crops and they,
they'll do a test on them and then these
guys have to go to court and they want
money from them.
It's like it's the most evil shit ever.
Monsanto is one of the most evil
corporations ever,
by the way.
And there was some fucking thing online
about them buying blackwater.
Uh,
I don't know if they did.
I don't know if they did,
but there was like people were like,
this is the end of the world,
just like the most evil organizations
ever.
And one's going to buy the other and
they're going to become one massive,
super evil organization.
Could you imagine there?
They want to fuck over the whole world.
They want to take over the food
industry.
They want to make sure that people have
to pay them for their crops.
You don't own your crops,
you don't own the seed.
You can't replant the seeds.
And we got an army.
We got an army that army that will do
anything we tapped.
I need to find out if that actually is
still happening or if it was bullshit or
if they just hired him for something.
Um,
yeah.
There's this great French documentary
life according to Monsanto,
which is on Google that people should
watch it.
It's crazy.
What's the seed called?
The one that doesn't,
um,
you know,
you have to keep buying it.
The not the shot.
This shotgun there.
It's something.
It's a
seat that doesn't,
you know,
it,
it's not a crop that will keep coming
back.
You have to plant it every season.
Um,
fuck modified seed that you have to
just.
The farmers are at Monsanto's mercy
because they can't just keep some of the
crops and like they,
these things die every year to keep
buying.
They've engineered dealer.
Yeah.
They engineered the uh,
what's this crazy world anyway.
But yeah,
no,
they're like,
you've looked at them.
Well,
okay.
Here's the answer there.
They're hiding it because it's a,
they've.
This is one,
one article said Monsanto Buys
Blackwater and then another argument or
another article rather says,
black has been sold via shell company
and a pair of private equity firms,
so does this mean Monsanto has actually
bought into Blackwater and they're
saying there's no way to know how creepy
and scary or these motherfuckers
when one of the biggest corporations
that controls the food on this planet
has its own private army.
Not Crazy.
Come.
This isn't being discussed.
Everybody wants to talk about how many
black guys,
Kim Kardashians.
Everyone wants to know gay people
shouldn't get married.
Yeah.
This has taken over the world and you're
worried about fucking guys getting
married.
Crazy thing is people think this is
ridiculous.
This is like hippie nonsense.
All this fucking.
You know,
what?
Are you doing this?
No,
no,
no.
This is big business is what this is,
is the biggest business in the world.
The number one business in the world
besides drugs is food and the only
reason why drugs is more than foods
because drugs is illegal.
You know,
foods worth way more than drugs.
Drugs should be cheaper,
but they're illegal.
You know,
I mean fuck man,
but it's probably not even close anyway.
More people spend way more money on food
than drugs anyway,
even though drugs are illegal.
Even though I forget what I was saying.
Like a mania would.
You'd have to be off the charts.
Everybody would have been off the
charts.
But anyway.
So how the fuck man,
how could this happen?
I man,
dude,
I.
that's so scary.
It's very scary.
I mean I just read like on another
similar kind of thing I just read about
there's gonna start selling genetically
modified salmon that grows twice as big
and in half the time and you're laying
there like,
oh,
we're not too worried about the cross
pollination and going into the why do
you have no,
and they're like,
oh,
the tests have proven that it's,
it's fine.
Like there's no really.
How long have you tested this on a
generation of people?
No you haven't.
No one has a fucking clue.
No fucking idea.
They're like,
oh,
we tried for three months.
He never.
No one got sick.
Let's put a new species of animal that
will be out on the market for people to
eat.
There's a fish that,
um,
let me just,
uh,
whenever an animal comes from another
ecosystem and invades as an alien thing
can ruin everything.
Man.
I think there's,
I think it's called the snake and I
think that's the name of the fish,
but it's a fish that I believe it's from
Africa.
I'm just talking out of my ass right
now.
I'll find out what it is.
But snakehead invasion is what I'm going
to look up because these fish,
they started showing up in,
in lakes and ponds.
Just eating everything dude.
Eating everything.
Yes.
Snakehead.
That's exactly what it is.
Yeah.
They're in.
They've turned up and lakes and rivers
all over the country and it's,
it's a real big problem because they're
like,
they're like invincible breed.
Like a motherfucker I'm looking forward
on here.
Um,
it doesn't say what country it comes
from Cobra.
Wikipedia.
See,
it's a.
it's a scary thing though,
man.
They just come in and like,
imagine if you're like,
the guy likes going fishing and they're
scary as fuck.
Looking man,
they look like some fucking crazy
dinosaur thing,
man.
Okay.
They are from Africa,
so I wasn't talking out my ass.
So this is the.
This is the fish.
It's.
It looks like.
Look at this shit.
It looks like a dinosaur.
Yeah,
it looks like a dinosaur.
I mean look at that fucking thing.
That's creepy.
Looking front extension and dudes just
have them for pets.
I had paranas for pets and it was
against the law because of that very
reason.
Yeah.
But I know a dude who knows a dude,
you know what I'm saying?
We'll get you some Palanas.
Yo.
I had to like get illegal paranas and
it's pretty bad as it was,
but it wasn't like your cat in there.
The feed them like what need you do?
I love my man.
Come on.
Well,
what?
It had no freedom.
Goldfish.
Goldfish is a.
is what they love.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's a trip.
Watching a feat to man.
You can feed them hot dogs and shit like
that too.
If you're really not into watching them
kill something,
but there's something so primal about
watching those fucking things.
Just to attack a school of goldfish and
the Goldfish,
it was really a sick thing that I should
do.
I used to get a bag of goldfish and then
I would sit.
I'd pull my bar stool in front of this
giant tank.
I just trying to take how many,
how many of the Pronto?
At one point I had 30 Jesus.
It was a big tank is huge tankers.
I don't know.
Hundreds of gallons.
I forget how many hundreds,
but it was really big.
Anyway.
It was made where we're a thousand.
It might have been over a thousand
gallons I think.
Whoa.
I don't even remember anymore.
It's been so many years.
Anyways,
big tank.
I had too many.
When I had like 30.
It was good number.
When I had like five five's a good
number because they get crazy and you
started to kick start killing each
other.
If you have too many of them are not.
Even if you have too many of them,
just one of them shows up with a limp.
That's a wrap.
Daisy,
even if they're not hungry,
they just attack them.
They just tack them and fuck them up.
So um,
I would uh,
dumped the goldfish in there and they
would look at the goldfish for a second
and they would like slowly move closer,
slowly move closer and then one of them
would go for it and when one of them
would go for it,
they would just dart,
snap and cut a goldfish in half and then
the blood would be in the water and then
it was on like donkey Kong.
And then I would sit there and watch
them go back and forth and chasing them
around these little driftwood things and
shit.
And the Goldfish don't know what the
fuck is going on.
And they're just getting cut down like a
Goddamn horror movie.
And their primal man,
they're fucking savage stealing dead
goldfish from each other.
Like one's got a half a goldfish.
The other one comes up and bite it off
of his face.
So after like a good,
like,
like killing.
When they would go nuts,
they would be missing lips and shit.
Their lips would be because there would
be stealing from each other and they cut
their own lips off,
so they were always like this.
Really.
They're creepy looking anyway,
but there were even more creepy when
they're.
They're white teeth were exposed and
they'd be swimming around his fucking
tank and a lot of people cut their lips
off just so they can see the white teeth
and you pull them out and you remove
their lips and then you put them back in
the water and they swim around and they
swim around like monsters.
They look.
They look even scarier that way.
Modified paranas dude.
There's a fucking crazy parana.
It's a.
it's a like a cousin to a persona and
they just fuck.
What is the name of it?
This big tiger fish and they just caught
one in the Congo.
This guy went and they had this TV show
about it.
He caught this thing in the Congo.
It's the nuttiest thing you've ever seen
in your life.
It's got teeth that are as long as great
white shark teeth,
enormous teeth,
and it looks like a monster.
It does not look like a real fish and
just this ridiculous mouth of giant
fucking teeth and just the dead eyes and
his big fucking plate covered body of
death,
just swimming through incredibly fast
waters and fucking things up and it's
huge.
It's a hundred pounds,
150 pounds.
They killed people.
They've bitten people's legs and shit.
Taking chunks out of them.
You fall in man,
they bite you.
If you're still in there,
they're going to keep biting.
Set.
It's a wrap.
There's a bunch of them,
man.
They really are like a giant Purana that
we're separated from these man.
Those things had the legs.
We'd all need to.
Well,
we're fucked.
If fucking mountain lions increasing
population in California,
especially southern California.
It's every couple of years.
Some asshole on a bike.
It's jacked by a cougar.
I know.
I love fucking hiking,
but I guess so smoking and going hiking
and I get so apparent.
I walk around and my brother came to
visit me.
I was walking around with rocks because
it's not discovery channel thing,
but people getting attacked by mountain.
Bring Mace if you want to bring
something.
Bring.
Like I had bear mace that I used to
bring when I would live in Colorado.
When I lived in Colorado,
I used to carry a gun.
I carry two guns once a gun always.
And Mace.
I bring Mace because bears.
You don't really want to shoot bears
man,
because first of all,
the nine millimeter you shoot a bear,
guess what?
You're not going to kill him.
You're just going to make them really,
really fucking mad.
You know?
And Colorado doesn't have too many.
Grizzlies are.
A lot of it was black bears,
but they could.
I mean Shit.
And they're in Montana.
They're in a lot of places you don't
know.
I mean they don't have a real accurate
number of how many grizzlies are out
there and if they've found a few in
Colorado it was because there was a zoo
that we went to that they had to
grizzlies that were in the zoo.
And the reason why they had them in
there was because they had gotten to use
to people and they start jacking
people's garbage and once they start
jacking your garbage,
that's it.
They know that that's a food source and
they never quit.
They just didn't ever move on to a new
neighborhood.
They just will camp out and just jack
your garbage every night so it becomes
an issue and they have to kidnap him.
Fuck it,
man.
That's when you see them out there.
I mean,
I never saw a bear in the wild,
but I did see a mountain lion.
But seeing a bear in the zoo and just
thinking about this thing is allowed to
roam around in the same area as you
like.
This is a monster.
Giant fucking enormous monster.
And sometimes they get really hungry.
Oh,
and let your kids don't fuck.
They'll fuck you up man.
Just see grizzly man.
No,
no,
no to you guys.
The best comedy ever.
Oh my God.
What's Grizzly man?
Grizzly man is a documentary about this
guy named Timothy Treadwell.
Timothy Treadwell was this guy.
It was like a love with grizzlies was
one of the weirdest things ever mad,
really strange,
and the guy was Uber Gay,
just really gay and completely in denial
and the way he would like face his
gayness was to live in the woods with
these fucking bears.
It was the strangest thing ever.
Has God.
There was so many deep psychological
issues going on with this guy barry
closet.
Yeah,
like the interview his friends and
they're like,
well,
he used to talk in an accent,
but then he stopped.
He just one of those guys.
I mean,
it's completely nuts and he'd be out
there.
I'm the only one who's out here saving
these bears.
Meanwhile,
the park rangers like,
you don't have to save them.
All right there bears.
No one's here not doing anything.
Like you're crazy.
You're living with these bears.
You're,
you're,
you're actually endangering the bears
because you're getting the beers used to
being in contact with humans and that's
what gets bears in trouble.
They get used to people being around
because he's around all the time and
like,
oh,
well let me go just jack this dude
picnic basket.
And then you gotta shoot him.
So what?
He's actually doing his fucking these
bears over,
right?
So this guy is just out there every
year.
I'm here saving these bath.
These parents without me,
they'd be nowhere.
And they're like,
he's.
He calls them my.
Has a bunch of names so I am.
Hello Mr.
Cupcake,
you know,
and the bear takes a shit and he runs up
to the pair shit.
He goes,
oh,
it's warm.
Oh it just came out of her.
But it just came out of her.
But this is warm.
Like this guy is touching it and he's
excited that he's in contact with this
shit that just came out of her ass and
I'm not kidding.
And he thinks it's a magical shit.
I could just amazed by this.
Amazing.
It's warm.
He actually said that she's feeling her
shit saying that it's warm because you
imagine if he was doing that to a woman,
a woman,
you know,
he runs into her bathroom and fucking
jacks are shit.
And he's holding onto it.
It's just came out of her.
But it's warm.
It's just as bizarre.
Just as bizarre to be doing that with a
fucking bear.
You weird.
Great movie at the end.
He dies.
Yeah,
sure it is.
It's um,
Werner Herzog.
Fucking fascinating because it seems
like Werner Herzog is not in on the
joke,
which makes it even more interesting.
It's like his guy is a brilliant
documentarian.
Does he know how hilarious is,
is because it doesn't appear that he
does because it's doesn't seem like he's
playing it off that way at all.
And even when he talks to the woman at
the end,
I would love to sit down with him,
like off the record and asked him a
question.
I would love to go blue.
Did you know that was funny when you
were doing it?
Yeah,
because it's God damn brilliant dude.
It's hilarious.
It's so funny.
I was like great.
Christopher guest movie deadpan
everybody to bring in like the sheriff
from up in Alaska.
Well I knew he was going to get in
trouble up there.
These interviews,
these people,
and they're talking about how like,
how he had to,
you know,
recognize the body and now they had to
shoot the bear because the bear was
still there,
like guarding over the bodies.
Yeah.
They had,
the guy had flown over.
Oh yeah,
you have to kill them once they start
killing people.
You have to cry.
But it was an old what it was.
Was he the guy they called it suicide by
bear.
And what happened was the guy had just
decided to stay way past.
You're supposed to and when you get to a
certain point in time,
the bears that are conscious or that are
up that aren't hibernating or all the
ones who are dying,
they're all really old and the really
old bears get desperate and they can't.
They can't get any food.
And they started killing their own
babies.
And when,
when you see bears killed their own
babies,
you're supposed to get the fuck out of
there,
right?
Because if they're killing their babies,
they're desperate.
It's fuck,
you know,
they're eating anything.
They eat their own goddamn babies.
And um,
he,
he basically went back and like October,
November when the bears are camping and
in,
and a bear killed him and took a long
time and there's a video,
but there's no,
there's no image because the lens cap
was on,
but the camera was running and they have
like seven minutes of him getting torn
apart by bears,
by this one bear.
And because the thing about bears is
they just start eating.
You see a real carnivore or rather real
Predator like a cat.
Cats kill you first because they want to
keep killing things and they don't want
to have to worry about fighting you.
You know,
the hyenas.
Hyenas just started eating.
And that's the same with bears.
Bears that get you down.
They just started eating monkeys.
Chimps,
chimps kill monkeys.
They just eat them.
They don't kill them first.
There's videos of chimps screaming while
I'm or monkeys rather screaming while
the chip has a hold of it's little body
and his biting its legs off,
pulling it apart.
And this monkey score reaming and it
looks like a little person.
It looks like a weird little person in
an outfit and it's getting ripped apart
by this champ.
Who's this chewing on it.
It's fucking dark dude.
And that's what bears do.
And that's what bear did.
The Timothy Treadwell just aidem for
seven minutes until he died somewhere.
That footage exists to no video,
man.
Only audio.
There was no video footage.
Yeah,
but Werner Herzog listened to it.
That fucking.
He didn't play it for us and he said
this,
this is too much for people to handle.
We need to burn this,
burn this like bitch.
Some the people decide maybe just being
a little over reactive.
Well,
how,
when did they,
when did you shoot that?
How long ago?
A few years ago.
It's like 2000 years ago.
Maybe.
Maybe even more than that.
It might've been like 2004 on watch this
video.
Every time somebody gets his head
chopped off,
my brother's like,
he'll check out the video.
I'm like,
what are you?
Well,
there's nothing graphic about it.
Two thousand five.
There's nothing graphic about it.
I mean,
they don't really show you,
but when they say the way they found out
that the guy had died was that um,
they flew in like with some supplies for
them and as the guy was flying in a
plane,
he saw a bear that was out,
which you thought was unusual and he saw
the bodies,
like he flew over and saw like this,
the white rib cage poking up of a guy
that had just been eaten.
He ate two of people.
He ate him and he ate his girlfriend
too,
and they are both fucked up there.
So they landed and they had a,
they had a land with rangers and rifles
and Shit,
and they had to kill the bear and the
bear that killed the bear and they left
the bear.
This is the really crazy thing.
And then they came back or a couple of
months later,
fucking nothing left.
Nothing of the body.
It had all been absorbed.
Animals had eaten in other bears at
eating,
at the bones were all crushed up,
was incredible.
They finally were a couple of rib bones.
It's really amazing.
We were talking about this giant grizzly
bear,
I mean they had photos of the bear and
video footage of the bear from previous
stuff that he had gotten before the bear
killed him back when they were salmon
running like they got the bear eating
fish and shit.
Dude.
Giant animal and it just within a few
months it's gone get really big before
you watch it though.
Oh Dude.
It's one of the greatest documentaries
ever.
Most unintentional comedy,
I think ever in a document that Richard
Simmons out in the woods and colony
brothers.
It really is like the Coen brothers did
it as a goof.
I mean,
I really.
I mean I was amazed,
but it's kind of perfect that the bear
ate him.
Like in terms of the documentary,
like sure hurts.
I was probably there going.
Yeah.
Well I believe he started the
documentary after the guy died.
Oh,
okay.
How did they.
He had video footage that he had shot
himself for years and years set up by
himself and he's so crazy who set up the
camera and he would look into the
camera.
I'm out here alone in this far as
protecting these bears because no one
else gives a shit.
No one gives a shit,
so fuck you park ranger.
Fuck you.
United States government.
Alaska.
He's just going off like screaming.
Okay,
let's try this again.
Take three.
And they'll do it like over and over and
over again.
And he obsessive Lee filmed themselves.
So they have,
not only do they have this incredible
wealth of footage from here,
but I watched the grizzly man diaries.
Okay.
Because he had so much footage.
They turned into a fucking reality show
seven years after this Doodad.
Okay.
And I watch it all the time.
There's a fucking reality.
She didn't know that.
This is like all the Easter after we're
done here in Bro.
Let's get something to eat.
We'll hit the fucking vaporizer.
Fucking have a good time.
It's genius,
man.
It's,
it's.
He's just gold.
He's gold all day.
I wish the motherfuck was still alive.
I would have them on the podcast in a
heartbeat.
Wasn't there a part in it where he goes,
everyone,
did you already say this?
Everyone thinks I'm gay.
Then he talks about it,
there's a part he wants with the camera.
He's like,
well,
you know,
I guess.
No,
this is what he said.
He goes,
it'd be so much easier if I was gay,
you know,
just can't.
I just can't find a girl.
Can't find the right girl.
I can't find the right girl.
Maybe it's because you're living in the
woods with monsters.
You fuck like which chicks want to be.
Put it in a nice roof over their head.
Okay.
They want to be taken care of.
They want a man who loves them and
supports them taking.
They don't want to.
Yeah.
Let's go live in a house.
Made of fabric.
Okay.
Um,
amongst.
You want me to sleep outside on the
ground with no more within fabric above
me while monsters roam around there.
My friends like it's Mr Cupcake.
Hey Mr.
Capp k,
when you eat me in a couple of months,
can you think you could start from the
headfirst,
like die quicker as fast seven minutes.
This guy dies.
Think about how fucking law.
Think about holding your breath for
seven minutes.
Right?
That's a long ass time now.
Thank you.
Can't do it now.
Think about something eating you seven
minutes of what you died.
You just pulling chunks out.
You're screaming and it's just eating
your feet and you're just squirting
blood like a broken faucet when it just
pass out a few.
I don't know,
man.
I don't know that you're like,
okay,
I'm dying and you accept it and then you
wake up when a bite your dick off six
more minutes.
You're like,
okay,
that still still conscious to just
starts eating your asshole.
Just big chunks and he's got his giant
Paul and he puts it on your cheek and
you just rip it out your ass or just
pulling up literally eating your asshole
while you're still alive.
Dude.
Fuck man.
Fuck a bear.
People in my neighborhood too,
and I lived in the Colorado mountains.
I'm like,
well,
if you see a bear,
you report it.
What the fuck are you talking about?
I'm going to shoot that thing.
I'm going to shoot the fuck out of that
thing.
If I had a rifle,
not with the pistol,
the pistol,
you got to use the main span.
Fucking scary animals.
God Damn.
We need them.
We need them in our woods.
Fuck you.
We do that can kill them all.
Put them in zoos.
I don't do the whole.
I don't.
I don't know if you guys serve,
but I have a bunch of friends at surf
and they want me to go.
I'm like,
you,
do you have any ideas like the size of
the monsters in there.
Guy Just died recently in Santa Barbara
and a half in front of his friends,
like if sharks were walking on land,
you'd go,
I'm not going.
Were those those?
Those monsters are hanging out.
You're going really on this little
board.
You're going where there are like things
that eat people that are twice or three
or four times the size of you.
You know what I am going to play.
If I'm going to surf,
I'm going to do it on the xbox and I'll
do this.
This is what I tell them.
Tell people
if there were three werewolves in the
country,
fact proven three werewolves,
would you ever be in the woods at night
on a full moon?
Why the fuck would you take that chance?
You wouldn't.
Okay,
well there's a million sharks you fuck.
And they're not just sharks when it's a
full moon there sharks every day and
they can't even stop because if they
stopped,
they drowned.
So they have to keep swimming and they
have to keep beating navy shoes and
license plates and tires and they'll eat
you.
They'll eat you bro,
and they'll eat you quick.
They take giant bites out of you and
your fucking.
I'm sure surfing is awesome,
but it ain't that off.
I wear shoes in the ocean and wouldn't
even fight like the biggest thing ever.
Can we save an oculus on that smart
thinking right there?
Yeah.
I mean people like we'll always like,
like this is another subject,
but people who might not be so scared of
things,
so paranoid of things like obviously a
lot of this is for entertainment folks.
I'm not shaking every time I walk by the
ocean,
but the point being logically and
realistically,
we're all going to die eventually.
Absolutely,
but that's not the fun way to go.
The Fun way to go is you live a long
life.
You fucking party your ass off.
You make a lot of good friends and
people miss you.
When you're gone.
You're surrounded by your friends and
loved ones.
This is passed to the next stage of his
existence.
Not,
oh,
look how pretty.
The water fucking thing is.
Just taking chunks out of Sadie.
I mean fucking huge man.
I mean there are sharks that are 30 feet
long out there.
What are you talking about?
30,
long,
30 feet long with giant mouths that have
so many teeth.
If one breaks off,
another one pops into its place.
There's no animal like it in the world.
Every other animal when they lose a
tooth or fucked,
okay?
If a lion loses his tooth,
managed to new,
young lions going to take over,
motherfucker.
You can't be gumming no gazelles.
How He protected me with them,
fucking shitty teeth that deadline and
dies up.
Not a shark,
they can lose 100 teeth.
What are clink?
Clink,
clink,
clink.
Just designed to fuck you up,
man.
You're drowning at the same time.
Horrible is drowning.
You're drowning while something is
eating your entire like those Parana
fucked up those Goldfish,
man.
I'm just scared of Karma,
I'm fucked.
A lot of goldfish.
Over a lot of goldfish to a watery
grave.
If there's any Karma out there,
I mean the universe does it really give
a fuck about the difference between life
of a goldfish or life of a person and I
took some pleasure in the death of
Goldfish and I set it up.
You know I introduced them.
Alien fish that aren't even supposed to
be in this environment.
I had a fake artificial environment in
my own home and I will use it for a
little goldfish.
Coliseum you playing God and playing
God.
Man,
I ain't going to no water.
I know what I did wrong.
I'm not going in there.
Make a genetically modified goldfish
fish going to get huge.
It's going to come for you.
Minutes can grow.
Legs is going to come knock on your
door.
Did you hear about the shit that's going
on in Russia?
Man?
What's going on in Russia?
The wolves.
The.
What is this going on in the screen
there,
Brian?
Some weird shit right there.
That's always been like a.
What is it?
Like the design.
Oh,
you put it there?
Yeah.
Oh,
you fucking Weirdo.
Trying to be artistic.
It's.
Anyway.
There's a pack of wolves in this area of
Russia.
There's unprecedentedly big.
It's 400 Woltz and they're acting
together and they're killing livestock
like horses.
They're acting together as a group.
It's a really scary and they.
They have groups of hunters that are
going after him.
Let me,
let me pull it up real quick.
Holy.
It's really scary.
You imagine you're in a woods stroll.
400 will do it.
It's really scary.
There's a video of wolves in Russia.
Have you ever seen the video on youtube?
Yo,
you gotta.
Check out this video.
It's fucking bad ass.
Have you ever seen it,
Brian?
Now some people think it's fake.
I don't.
I do not believe it's fake.
It's a video of these guys that are
pulling over people in Russia,
they're pulling people over for traffic
violations and it's,
you know,
they're right by the wolves,
the woods rather.
And as they're in there,
one guy's pulling a guy over,
a guy yells who's on the other side of
the street and as he yells to the guy
who's the comp panics,
he yells something in Russia,
Russian panics and gets into the car of
the people he pulled over,
jumps in it quick and as he jumps in it,
this pack of wolves runs down the
street.
It's a mother fucker dude.
And as they're running,
they go,
why do people think it's fake?
A lot of people don't think is real.
You know,
people would call fake mean looking at
you.
You call faking everything I pull,
pull it up.
I'm a pack of wolves.
Police officer.
Pull up,
pull that up on Youtube.
But anyway,
so this is super pack of wolves is
terrorizing this fucking town.
They have killed 30 horses in four days.
Oh yeah.
What?
They've never seen anything like it
before.
And they've had to put bounties on
wolves heads.
So they're putting 210.
I don't know what it is,
a because it's pounds.
I believe it is.
It might be euro's 200,
10 euros.
It's probably euro's,
right?
Do they go into the year?
That was a vodka by the way.
It was.
It fake.
It was figure.
Okay,
well this isn't a podcast.
How did they find it?
How did they get to volunteer?
I searched it and it says a wolf attack.
Videos of viral ad for vodka brand.
But it doesn't even have the.
Pulled the video.
It's pretty.
It does seem a little bit to uh,
well filmed.
Did it too good of a job.
So anyway,
this,
think about this shit man.
The,
the,
the is up there are minus 49 degrees
Celsius and it killed off all the normal
prey of these wolves says wolves thrive
in cold weather.
But there's a lot of animals.
What are you doing,
man?
Just cue that shit up.
So we'll have to watch this guy's gay ad
presents.
I present here it goes.
So yeah,
see that looks like to.
Well framed,
you know,
that's a good traffic camera.
Both,
both cars are in frame,
but it's pretty dope man.
Alive when it happens.
I wish it was real.
She was aware it wolf.
Yeah.
So,
I mean think about that temperature
right there.
Forty nine degrees Celsius.
That's fucking crazy.
That's Edmonton minus 49 degrees.
Yeah.
And so,
um,
these wolves have nothing to eat.
So they all figured out how to get
together.
And this population,
this town is only 1300 people.
So wrap your head around that.
1,300
people.
400 wolves.
So almost for every three,
three people,
there's a wolf.
Oh Man,
what the fuck man.
Get the fuck out of that.
Every three people there's a wolf.
The chances of you dying by wolf attack
are like,
oh,
like the chances of you dying of old
age.
It's terrifying and it's just starting
to happen again.
There's been two instances in the last,
like fucking 100 years or so,
and they've both been within the last 10
years of people getting killed by
wolves.
It's on record.
We used to think that like wolves are
cool,
man.
They're like,
dogs,
man.
They're like Randall's.
No,
they're fucking killers.
They'll kill you too,
you know,
if they catch you alone.
We used to have like all the member,
the Old Walt Disney movies,
there was a woes like try to get beauty
and the beast.
The wolf would fucking sneak up on him.
So yeah,
you'd have to fucking fight off the
wolves that wanted to kill beauty.
Right?
Remember that shit,
they attacked them.
That's real.
We just have fucked them over so bad in
this country that we started to have
respect for them.
Again,
like wolves aren't so bad,
so you're cool man.
We need them.
They're beautiful.
You know,
they represent freedom.
Rules represented freedom.
Like there's a never think about walls,
but this guy thinks about was everyday I
think about because I'm closer to an
animal than you are for sure.
There's one percent DNA differential,
whatever the fuck it is between humans
and chimpanzees.
I'm closer to Mr Cat.
Goddammit.
I'm too close.
I want to go into the woods.
Some gravitating.
I gravitate towards wild.
If we lived in or if there was a rain
forest,
I'd fucking live in it.
If we have a rain forest right here,
I figured out how do you kill the bugs?
Where do you go?
Electricity.
Can you zap them?
I need to have an area around,
but we live in a fucking rain forest.
It'll be the shit.
Yeah.
Buy Shit.
You mean insanely dangerous and boring?
Blinders can kill you and spiders can
kill you.
I'm not going there.
How about spiders to destroy your
hormones?
Man,
there's a fucking Brazilian spider that
we talked about.
What the fuck was I thinking?
I'm just scared of.
I don't remember.
I'm just scared of regular spiders in my
bed because you read that.
Some of these spiders are poisonous here
in California and they hide in your
shoes and your birch.
Yeah.
They're black and brown.
I saw brown outside my house.
The other glue.
So the scary ones because rec looses.
They do something to your skin.
It causes your skin to die so it causes
your
tissue to dissolve.
It's really fucked up,
man.
Necrosis.
I believe it's called and when they bite
you,
they unload on you with all this fucking
toxin and it just crushes your skin.
Whereas like giant gaping wounds occur
from one little spider bite because all
the area around your skin dies and rots.
It's scary shit,
man.
Really Spooky Shit.
And again,
I'm taking this flashlight,
Brazilian wandering spiders.
That's what it is.
And I believe we've talked about it on
the podcast before you got to look this
up.
Were you always a musician like growing
up or did you don't change subject
motherfucker.
We're talking about vipers and shit.
I wanted to bring up this,
this one thing,
and we're talking about less the,
the Hornet versus Hornets versus wasps
thing that you mentioned the.
Was it hornets versus wasps?
The,
uh,
when the Hornets attack the bees nests
or whatever.
Yes.
You see that,
that military shit scary.
Those are monsters.
I mean if they were big,
they were like horses.
Can you imagine a beam of the size of a
horse called the Burmese Russell Viper.
That's what it is to Russell Viper.
And what these things,
they caused uncontrollable hemorrhaging
of your pituitary gland where all your
sex hormones are controlled.
So if you get bit by this fucking thing
and if you survive the bite,
which you probably won't,
you'll be permanently impotent.
And you become like a unit,
like you lose all your pubic hair,
you stop,
you stop producing testosterone,
your body just gets jacked,
you get neutered.
And if you get neutered by a bite,
no,
this is a python.
Oh yeah.
With the,
with the spider does is a spider brakes
your dick by forcing you to have raging
uncontrollable hard ons that you can
like painful agonizing hormones are hard
ons.
And when the heart opens over your
Dick's broken.
So either you're dead,
either you die.
And then when,
by the way it's the most potent toxic in
any spider.
So it either kills you or you live and
your Dick's broken forever.
So both animals break your Dick.
It's just like they're instinctively
worth.
We're afraid of spiders.
Just a tiniest bit like,
ah.
Because some of those can fuck you.
Fuck up.
Yeah.
There's genetic memories I'm absolutely
convinced.
And I've read about it before where
they,
this guy I'm a rupert sheldrake,
was talking about,
he's an,
I believe it's an evolutionary
biologist,
and he was talking about how animals
are,
what people are really terrifying of
monsters,
like no matter what the real dangers of
your environment,
if you're a child and you live in New
York City,
you know,
you're not worried about car accidents
or rapists or you're worried about
monsters.
And the reason being is because there's
some ancient,
ancient memories of us when we used to
get killed by Jaguars and shit,
you know,
and we're scared of the night and we're
scared of monsters because that's really
what they were a man,
you know,
and the ones that survived of this,
he carried this incredibly potent,
terrifying memory.
And it's actually in printed into people
genetically.
You know,
we have this idea of instincts,
you know,
when people have certain instincts.
But then what does that mean?
Okay,
what his instincts mean,
you,
you know,
something already.
Okay?
What,
how do you know something already?
Is it because of past experience of your
ancestors in as it comes through your
genetics?
Well,
how much stuff goes in there,
how much information is now.
What they've shown is that means in some
ideas,
even useless ones like racism can be
transmitted through genetics.
So the same thing that causes you to
like have an instinct,
you know,
to not do something like don't go,
don't go near Heights.
Oh No,
you already know it.
Instinctively.
The same thing is actually you can
transmit other ideas into people's
heads.
You know,
you can transmit even talent maybe into
people's heads.
It's pretty fucking tripping when you
think about it because we don't know.
We don't have a documentation of where
all our information comes from.
I mean,
how much of your information is from
your ancestors?
How much of it is from all these people
that have lived before you,
that have made mistakes and learn from
them and you sort of have this internal
wisdom thing going on because of that.
I believe that totally.
Right?
Yeah.
When you meet someone who is wise beyond
their years,
you know,
what is that?
Is it that they've had an incredibly
life that's
a possibility or is it that,
you know,
somehow or another they have gotten a,
a rich history of people who have
survived and learn shit and it's
incorporated into their DNA?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
And it's very egotistical also to think
that,
oh,
I'm,
I'm just a smart person where I'm very
careful because I'm afraid.
Like,
it's like,
no,
you are afraid.
You have millions of years of people
going.
That is bad.
That is good.
That is bad,
that it's good.
It's not either or.
I mean you certainly have learned.
You certainly are smart and there's,
you know,
some people will most certainly do learn
better from fucked up situations.
There's a lot of them that absolutely
do.
Yeah.
I got a lot of buddies who don't learn,
man.
There's a lot of that going on,
Yeah.
There's a lot of people that don't ever
learn and you just got to constantly
fucking talk to him about shit,
dude.
Come on really full Kim.
Yeah.
She's got a third Dui and I'm like,
really?
Like are you like was I see I don't get
that because I am very bad at drinking
and driving,
but I'm 30.
No,
I'm really good at it and I think,
I don't know if it's well,
how well do you drink and drive?
Well,
I mean I think having a few beers,
it's considered drinking and driving,
so I probably drink and drive everyday
to listen.
First of all,
you're just kidding because cops listen
to this dummy.
They ever pull you over for a fan of the
podcast.
You know what I'm saying is I get out of
the car.
Which comedy club you're going to.
What I'm saying is that anytime you go
out,
you have maybe a couple of drinks.
You go in your car that's considered
drinking and driving.
You know,
if you have two beers in you that's
drunk.
Hey,
whenever you know,
whenever Brian is wrong about something,
he gets very excited.
He knows his voice.
No,
it's how much,
how much you went about,
I bet you money two beers is drunk and
we get pulled over.
Yes,
that's what I'm saying.
Especially man,
that's what I do.
If I'm going anywhere,
I'm drinking alcohol.
My problem,
my problem is I don't do the two.
Like if I have two or three even I'm
like,
all right,
I'm big boy.
I know how to stay in between the lines
and stuff,
but the problem is is if I did get
pulled over,
of course I would get a Dui.
What I want to know is these three,
these people that have three of them are
not usually the case.
Is that usually the case that or I mean,
is your friend like blackout drunk
driving or is he.
You know,
just like just friends.
I don't know.
Maybe it's just got bad luck.
Bad lesson.
Only three times have ever had more than
one drink.
This guys got good luck.
Really?
It's worse than that.
Are you done after three?
He's done because he may go to jail.
I'm never going to do that again.
Really after two people are scary.
Drunks and cars.
People were scary people.
I mean that's the real problem is
there's too many of us and we can't help
everybody get their shit together.
So you're always going to be around a
bunch of people that are broken no
matter what our.
The way our
society exists,
it's just too God damn big.
It's too big and the competition is too
powerful and too strong for us to pay
attention to these people that are
falling by the wayside.
So if you don't pay attention to them,
well all these fucking idiots,
they're just running around,
slamming into people and you can't fix
them.
Began with eggs on man.
This is just the candidate evolved the
whole world.
It's like God damn,
I only got a certain amount of years.
This is ridiculous.
There's nothing you can do to help them.
They have to help themselves and they
don't want.
They don't even think there's anything
wrong with them.
You know,
like fuck you bitch.
enrolling with me,
bitch.
You imagine that you end of your life is
some idiot who's just like fucking
wasted gets his car.
I can drive home.
It happens all the time,
mack.
It's terrifying
and no one know and there's so many of
them out there that it's almost nothing
you can do about it.
You just have to be vigilant,
keep an eye out and be very careful as
you drive and getting connected in any
way randomly on purpose to fucking nuts
to people that suck to dummies.
So many of them out there,
man.
We all know him.
We all know dudes who are just beyond
fixing.
There's nothing.
I know a bunch of dudes that if I knew I
could get away with it,
I fucking shoot him.
Right,
right in the head.
If I was alone in the woods and it was
like armageddon time and like there was
no more media and cell phones didn't
work anymore and I thought,
this dude be a problem.
I just walk them in the woods.
Come on,
let's go for a walk.
Man.
I saw some deer over here.
You might help me hunt.
Bow Hunt.
It's over there.
Yeah,
she fucking.
I remember you said one of the people in
Austin and scared the shit out of
whoever we were with.
I can't remember.
We were like,
why are you being says he being serious.
Tell them mice and men.
You just bring your friend.
Look over there.
We're going to go to that looks to the
pickup chicks all night.
We're going to get wasted.
It's going to be a good time.
Yeah.
There's certain people that you worry
when you're around them.
There's certain people that you feel
like they're going to victimize your
loved ones.
You know,
there's certain people like certain,
like a certain level of of criminal,
certain level of violent offender and
random violent offenders.
People rape and beat women up and then
you know,
it could be your mom,
it could be your sister,
it could be your daughter.
I should be dead,
dead.
Not In jail,
not for a year,
not for a day.
Shoot them and let's move on.
Okay?
We got a broken person.
We can't fix them.
Their favorite thing to do is to hurt
people.
The favorite thing to do is to hurt
people that you love and you're the
vulnerable ones.
The women really kill it.
Kill it.
Now,
killer would fucking fire bullets.
Whatever's cheapest.
Fuck Cam.
Sorry.
Come back as a butterfly.
Suck my cock by Bang,
Bang,
Bang.
Fuck you.
Stupid.
A humane level so he doesn't know he's
going to die.
It doesn't even matter if it's humane.
Just fucking shoot him.
What is his last moments are important.
You know,
don't torture them,
but you know,
what does the police stop?
Shut the fuck up.
It doesn't matter if yellow,
you're going to shoot him in the head to
yell at him.
Yeah.
Right.
Well,
animals in the zoo.
I mean,
how many animals in the zoo need to be
fed and what are we going to give him?
Steak.
That's stupid.
Give them chickens.
You fucking
beeble man.
Get some cons.
Throat concen there.
I bet bears would love to eat.
I'm tired of berries too.
Tired to picnic baskets.
Just throw a net cage.
Some fucking guy has been busted for the
fifth time.
Drinking and driving slides into a
family of five.
Thrown in that fucking cater.
Dana white will be in charge of that.
And this colosseum now.
That's what I take over the UFC.
Dan is going to retire.
They're going to ask me to take his job.
I'm going to go.
Okay.
I've got an idea though.
Sit down.
Listen.
Okay.
After the nuclear war,
life is cheap too.
That's the problem.
If there was,
if we could go back in time right now to
the coliseum,
you know,
what would you do?
Would you stand up and say,
you must stop this please.
What are you doing?
No,
you would sit down and you'd go,
you're going to drink that wine.
Yeah.
Fuck.
It would be sitting there.
We'd be drinking wine right next to us.
There'd be some old dude fucking some
boy in the ass.
You know?
That's how they rocked it back then.
It would just bend them over the fucking
rails,
the coliseum and bang them in the ass
while the while the things are going on.
Dude,
they were banging little boys left and
right back down and you just had to look
away,
look away and take us to be banging
boys.
We'd like a time machine and you're
like,
it's just so culturally accepted and
like everyone's doing.
All of a sudden you're like fuck.
And you're like,
why am I bugging this kid?
oh well it's kind of accepted it.
And then you go back to the future and
like,
what did you do?
A wig.
That is so funny.
Oh my God.
What?
How long would it take you to think in
jail before you started going gay?
Never.
You never go to yammer would go again.
What if it was like a really feminine
guy?
Look really soft.
Hardly any appeal.
Masturbation forever.
Like everyone who says they wouldn't
like,
you're like,
I'm sure those fucking dudes when they
were going to jail,
like I'm not going to be gay.
And like 15 years down the line,
like,
well I feel like fuck it.
Something that only gets 15 days,
man.
Yeah,
I think they just start getting addicted
right away.
In the Mexican community,
they call it gay for the stay.
There's a thing with a,
a lot of people that go to jail and then
do some gay shit,
but they only do it in jail when they
get out.
They're not gay at all.
He ever see that American me,
that Edward James almost moving.
There was a lot of that going on that
movie.
Like he would come out and it was all
fucked up sexually,
just wanted to rape chicks,
bang him in the ass because that's how
you would get guys in jail.
Yeah.
It was really creepy movie man.
It was my first real exposure to the
Mexican gang culture that I've ever had
or any la gang culture.
You know that in colors.
I watched a music video for colors the
other day.
I forgot about that one night man.
Talking Co's as ice tea before he played
a cop on TV.
The most ridiculous shit ever.
Iced tea as a cop on TV.
It's like,
what?
What,
how did that happen?
He had a song called cop killer.
A song.
Okay.
It wasn't a party he was playing.
He wrote that Shit.
You know I'm a motherfucking cop.
Killer number.
He was asked.
He was in a a wrap.
A rock for sure.
Body count.
Body count,
body motherfucking can button.
That was some hard.
Met Him at the comedy store one night
here.
Who's in the audience at the comedy
store when he was cool.
Yeah.
I met.
Make some joke.
I forgot what it was,
but I was a big ice tea fan when I was
in the newspapers.
I used to listen to a iced teas,
rap albums.
Let's get buck naked.
You didn't fuck.
Holy Shit.
We got some great ship.
It's just so weird seeing them playing a
cop.
It's like,
what?
Huh?
It is playing a dad.
You can sit down back there and
yeah.
Ice Cube ice cube rather than this.
The Dad.
Yeah,
man.
He's a duty as a dad.
I understand all that,
but God damn dude,
if easy you were alive.
He'd be like on two and a half men or
something.
We take it out of his mouth and go,
will you stop that?
That's gay.
Yeah.
Body count had the song where they.
He kills his mom.
Just flush her down at toilet.
Were kids going wrong?
He went as dark as he could.
It was easy.
Either first guy to ever die from AIDS
in the road or in the entertainment
world.
Was it
for Asher?
What was it?
Easy to remember who died?
First of all?
I know Arthur Ashe database,
right?
Yeah.
Easy.
He was one of the rare ones because I
remember when easy he died of AIDS.
I was like,
Holy Shit.
Like I was thought this was just the
beginning and I'm looking down the line
at some madmax situation where I'm
walking around town with a fucking one
of those Chinese facemask things on,
you know,
like you always see the Chinese people,
the airports.
I'm like,
what the fuck man?
Is this really gonna Happen?
Like everyone's just gonna start
dropping like flies and then it just
stopped.
Yeah.
And you're like,
what the fuck was easy?
He wasn't magic.
Johnson was.
It was not fucking the fleshlight.
It's weird man.
It's weird,
right?
What the fuck's up with Magic Johnson?
Like I'm Kinda freaked out.
It's,
it's crazy.
I've heard a bunch of different stories.
I can't really comment.
I've heard stories about him taking
medication and I've heard stories that
he doesn't need the medication anymore.
And then I heard he started,
stopped taking the medication.
His symptoms started reoccurring.
The weird thing is that he's.
He tests a negative.
Apparently he taste tests HIV negative
because the way HIV works is what you
can really test is you can test for the
antibodies.
I don't think they can accurately test
for the actual virus inside you.
Very tricky.
Well the first guy ever,
they kind of the who was HIV positive,
like through like,
it's not clear how it happened,
but I'm the first HIV positive.
They cured it somewhere in
Sweden or something.
Oh,
with stem cells,
right?
Yeah.
With the stem cells,
right?
Yeah.
That was recently.
Like a month ago or so.
How much should they get accomplished
with stem cells?
They have to dance around stuff and they
have to like,
like,
like the skin gun.
Have you heard about this thing that
they've got?
There's a new thing that they've figured
out how to do,
where they can actually take cultures
from your skin.
They reproduced with your own stem cells
and then they spray it in sort of a gun
on your,
um,
on your skin where it's burned and it
only takes like a certain amount of time
to cultivate like an hour two to
cultivate.
They can do it really quickly.
They reproduce this stuff and then they
spray it on you and it radically cuts
down healing time radically.
Like they showed this one guy who had
been burnt in a fire and then he looked
like he didn't have a fucking scratch on
them.
They showed images of this guy,
giant blistering second degree burns big
welts all over his hand and shit.
Well,
they spray this shit on him man.
And it builds within four days you've
got like Nu skin and it looks healed.
It's a trip and it's all stem cells.
But people say
hell though.
It's from his own body though.
This is what people don't understand.
You don't have to kill babies.
Get stem cells there.
Everyone thinks that everything comes
from the fetus,
but you don't have to.
And now they have a way to reverse it.
Like to take your own and reverse it to
like,
it's,
I've fucking done what people thought
they were going to encourage abortion
because
babies,
they needed stem cells from fetuses.
Yeah.
You know a god damn man.
You know,
let him,
let him work with Shit.
It's like these nutty Christians and
have these Kooky ideas about what they
should and shouldn't do with tissue and
cells.
Like what the fuck,
man,
what should you do if a girl has an
abortion,
she just flush it.
You're telling me if there's something
that you can learn in there that can
unlock the secret to immortality or cure
cancer or whatever the fuck it can do,
you're telling me you should just throw
it away because it's dead and it's
immoral and that Nina,
somehow none of the.
You're profiting off of abortion,
but the reality is people are so creepy.
They probably would start doing
abortion,
right?
They would start encouraging them.
You want a fucking baby shit.
They yell,
Dude.
How long before there is abortion porn?
Think about that.
People like just how long before they
would start paying for abortions.
We had this fucked up with porn.
Sex probably already is.
Listen to this.
We had a porn star on that 90 show
podcasts I did yesterday that was eating
out a girl and started bleeding and they
were like,
you know,
she started her period and found out it
was a miscarriage into her mouth.
So it was he,
she was eating a pussy probably if
somewhere like guys would pay a lot of
money and I'm so sad right now.
Right now.
Well that's not anybody's fault there.
No,
no that,
that was Kayla page.
So support Caleb Patriot.
You were telling me about her.
Right.
So you,
you've been doing these naughty show
podcasts.
Are you going to keep doing those to
everybody about the other podcasts you
have because you have a website,
[inaudible] dot TV.
Right.
And all of the podcasts are there.
They're all in it.
Ask
us like,
what is his desk was shit,
what?
Are you guys bad as?
No,
it's totally not that.
Does it opium from opium.
Anthony nicknamed us the desk for a long
time ago because I came onto the opiod
anthony show and at the time it was my
friend Tate Fletcher,
who was on the ultimate fighter and he
was on the show at the time.
He came with me and Eddie Bravo,
who's the Jujitsu guy,
so they're just my friends.
We were just traveling together and so
they came into the studio and a cop
goes,
oh,
Joe Rogan brought into the death squad
and then we just started like,
that's right with a desktop,
so juvenile and ridiculous and so over
the top and retarded.
So we decided to keep it.
So we did this naughty show podcasts.
It's usually a porn star and Sam
Tripoli's 90 show and Sam,
who's our buddy who's been on the
podcast a bunch of times and I did a
bunch of touring with Sam up and up in
Canada.
We did Toronto together.
Sam's awesome Jason Team.
Uh,
and so anyways,
it's once a week.
Jason Tubes.
Austin too.
I won't leave you out there,
dude.
Yeah.
You know,
I love you anyway.
Three squad that TV.
And so as all the pilots,
we do a lot of fun,
they also do,
whenever there's a ufc they get hammered
and they watched the UFC together and do
their own coinciding podcasts,
like talking shit about fights as they
go down.
And sometimes you even had joey on that
one.
One we have Joe fucking fun was,
it was great.
Got to go watch the UFC with Joey.
I have to accommodate and he sits next
to joe ideas,
you know,
you can't get any better entertainment.
And Joey Diaz last the last UFC hung on
acid drops two tabs of acid and watching
cage fights and they all,
I mean,
what was that like?
What was that like sitting there with
him for six hours?
Well it's like you're in bed with them
because the seats are so small.
So you kind of like on his lap like
holding like a,
like a big stuffed animal so that you've
got you,
you got that.
But then you've got like the most
hilarious commentary ever.
What's cool is that,
that that's what we do on the UFC drunk
as we pretty much,
you know,
we'll have some people like that,
Joey Diaz and stuff like that and just
getting drunk and watching us sees and
it's kind of like a commentary,
see a lot of people,
lot of your fans like to rewatch the
UFC.
So it's like,
hey no,
turn it on with our commentary this time
and it says a bunch of other comics just
doing your job.
But,
but drinking and smoking way do it the
right way.
Yeah.
Well I could never do it the right way
to.
Because a lot of things you say when
you're fucking around with your friends
are very disrespectful,
you know,
you say good,
I bitch,
what the fuck?
I tell you,
you know,
hope you brought your jammies.
Guys will sit when they're drunk and
they're stone and they're talking shit.
But they would never say that to the
fighter.
A fighter to hear that,
uh,
one.
Anybody else,
even if it's only between friends as a
goof.
So you know what Joey could say is so
much different than anything I could
say.
Jerry says crazy shit sometimes.
Som on the year,
Alex,
Alex.
Oh my God.
It's so fucking.
He's the funniest guy that's ever lived.
We did
Vegas two weeks ago,
dude.
He came up and he opens up the show,
which is the perfect way to do it
because Joe is not like an act election.
Do look in our.
He doesn't have time to do an hour and
it's not.
He doesn't the,
his pace.
He's got this destructo 15 minute pace
and that's what he does.
He doesn't want to do a 45 minute set.
So when I take Joey on the road with me,
it's like I'm taking another headliner.
I mean he's a fucking headline or any
opens and it goes up and just some it
dude he was,
he made me laugh so hard.
I literally fell down.
I was leaning against a wall.
We were all back there.
We were on,
like Joey was onstage and we were in
like the alleyway that leads to the
stage where the curtains are at the,
uh,
the Lion King Theater and Amanda Lee,
Bang,
big giant ass fucking place and we're
leaning up against the wall and joey's
killing so hard.
We're all rocking back and forth and
dudes are bending.
People are slapping their legs were all
like moving around.
We're standing still,
but nobody was standing still.
You're laughing.
I,
I literally fell down.
I fell down.
I drop to a knee and that's all just
crushes.
Just get this bit about.
This.
Yoga is taken yoga lately and he's a 68
year old lady and his yoga class.
I'm going to fuck that old bitch.
I swear to God.
Joe Rogan is.
Get this bit about it and it's.
We were crying laughing man.
He said we had just been about getting
in a fight,
a true story about a fight that he got
in with a nun when he was a kid.
Oh,
you got to fucking see it,
man.
Is that the funniest shit you've ever
seen?
Anything he says is hilarious.
He's such a fucking treats in Arizona
this weekend too.
Yeah.
Where's he at?
The new club,
I believe.
No,
no,
no.
He's on some completely different thing.
Yeah,
because they got upset with him,
but he wasn't doing the new club and
he's like,
you're not even open yet.
Stupid.
Danny murders with them.
Damer.
But a joey is a,
he's a,
he's one of those guys,
man.
It just makes you.
There's him back then when he was really
young.
That's what I met Joey.
Grab that picture man.
Grab that picture for the folks on
Ustream.
You'll be able to see this for folks.
Um,
it on itunes.
I don't know if it's available online
anymore.
I have to upload it.
But this was Joey Diaz when I first met
him and joey only weighed like,
you know,
like fucking 200,
10,
215 pounds up bay guy.
So He's been on like a big football
player looking guy.
And this is him right after he started
doing comedy.
I met him like a couple of years after
he started when he moved from Seattle to
La because the economy store guy.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He's just such a fun fucking guy.
There's people that you meet in your
life and they're just the life of the
party,
you know?
No one in my life has ever been the life
of the party.
Like Joey Diaz,
you know,
I've,
I've met a couple of crazy people that
are cool to hang around with every now
and then,
but no one just gets shit jumping.
Like Joey Diaz when he goes on stage
dancing and the right away just sets the
tone and the,
you know,
he's,
he's the fucking man.
Dude.
He's so fun.
So important man.
Have Fun.
Fucking cool people in your life.
You know?
Is that the most important thing in
life?
It really is,
right?
Yeah.
More than anything else.
Being some rich Khan who's no friends,
that's gotta suck bad man.
You know,
being some dude living in some giant
fucking mansion,
14 Ferrari's movies in sweatshops and
shit like,
and the social network.
It sucks to be rich and by yourself.
It's got to be.
But how would a dumb thing to say isn't
important?
Runes,
you love me.
You see things when you have kids,
you see everything through the eyes of
children's shows.
My daughter took all fucking log or a
log and her party the other day.
I swear to God,
look like Joey Diaz.
Shit in there.
I couldn't believe how big it is.
It's shocking.
I almost took a picture of it,
but I just thought that's disrespectful,
but my daughter's shits on twitter.
I just wanted everybody to see it.
Like you need to take a look at this.
This doesn't even seem normal.
I need to go to a doctor.
Her shit was like my forearm.
Was that her first big shit?
Now she takes logs.
She's my daughter.
She's a little savage.
Savage eaten meat and shit.
Shit.
I bought Venison Jerky and she has tears
into this shit.
Just chewing up venison jerky.
It's really weird.
Then you look at little babies.
I got the newest baby baby Rogan number
two is only.
She's almost nine months old.
And when when she gets food like it
doesn't matter like she can eat like
solid food,
but you've got to watch her.
You gotta be careful.
You know,
you've got to make sure that she can't
get anything she could choke on.
So,
uh,
but she always screams for food and one
of the things she likes to do is get
bones,
so I still like put bones in her mouth
and lick the bones and it's like a big,
like a,
um,
like a rib bone,
you know,
and it's just so weird to watch this
little baby with a bone from a dead
animal completely transfixed on this
thing.
She has one fucking tooth man.
She's got one tooth and she's non at
this bone with meat on it.
And like if you tried to take it from
her,
she will fucking scream.
I mean screamed the baby wants to murder
the animal and you know,
just instinctual nature more than
anything else.
I've given our apples.
I've given her bananas.
I've given her a bunch of shit before
and she likes him.
It's all good.
It's all nice,
but nothing like that bone.
You give her a bone.
It's just like giving a dog a bone,
you know,
you give a ball,
a dog dog food,
like,
Hey,
thanks for the dog food.
You give a dog a bone and you test how,
what your relationship is with him,
you know,
because you want.
Might want to take that back.
I want that bond back.
Oh,
what's up bitch?
I found your line.
This is the line.
You know,
my dad gave me a few times,
taken his bone really well.
Here's a biter.
I got him at the,
uh,
the shelter.
Oh,
right away.
He was fighting.
I was like,
fuck,
I got to.
Is a year and a half.
Well,
uh,
yeah.
He was like,
no,
no.
Small.
What kind?
Twenty five.
He,
I'm a fuck a Boston terrier and a cocker
spaniel.
So it kind of looked like a baby lab
kind of.
But he was fucked up in the head man.
And like a young young boys like teenage
boys,
he did not like,
he hasn't fucked up owners for sure.
Like he did not.
He couldn't sit,
give the par.
I taught them that 15 minutes,
but the,
he was clueless when I got him.
So he was like,
Kinda fucked up.
How long have you had them now?
Uh,
you know,
he's dead.
He died like last year.
But uh,
sorry.
No,
no,
not at all.
And he say,
sorry,
I'm not really sure.
I don't like that dog.
My Dog's died to all right.
You're like,
yeah,
you only one bro.
Fucking dead de one.
One one bro.
Uh,
but yeah,
he'd bite mother fucking little bone.
The bone and the weed man.
He like,
and I wouldn't get my dogs so I'm not
one of those guys.
I during,
I'm to get my dog stone,
but I'd see him and all of a sudden he's
stoned and I'm like,
fuck,
I had a piece of cookie.
No.
And he
good.
I had a dog that was um,
she was a rescue dog too.
And we got her high accidentally wants,
me and Joey were in my office and old
house just hitting a bong and this is my
early.
We'd days I was just learning how to
smoke weed and I couldn't believe that
I'd gone 30 years of my life without
knowing about weed and I was just going
to overboard so we me and joey got ball
lasted in my office and the dog was so
paranoid.
It was so crazy.
She was running from everything and
hiding under furniture.
I couldn't get it to come out.
It was weird.
I was like,
why are you hiding?
I'm like,
oh,
she's high as fuck at the dog.
Got a contact time hanging out with us.
It's weird.
It was a rescue dog too.
So her,
her,
her being high.
It was not like a happy puppy that you
raised being high.
Like if I got high with Johnny.
Johnny doesn't have any fears.
Johnny's happy dog.
He's got a good life,
you know,
but you get a rescue dog.
That dog was like three or four years
old before I got her nose and she was
living on the street in la,
eating out of garbage cans and they
caught her and she had to change her
bodies covered in mange when I first got
her.
So I had to treat her with chemicals,
had it with some sort of medicine.
I had a washer and I ended up like just
feed her.
She ate like insane amounts of foods.
You could not eat enough.
She was.
She was a voracious appetite.
So voracious.
She was sneaking out of my house.
Okay.
Even though I fed her,
she's a fat pig.
She was sneaking out of my house.
She would call.
She had a hole that she found wish you'd
go under the fence.
So you go to the neighbor's house,
tip over the garbage,
eat their garbage and then sneak back in
the yard.
And I had no idea she was doing it and
she was doing it forever.
I'm like,
this dog's fat as fuck.
I'm giving her diet dog food.
She's fatter,
man.
What the fuck is happening?
She just kept
clever duck.
Well they have this thing where they
feel like they're never going to have
enough food.
You know,
they can't stop eating.
They just,
they will keep eating until they get
sick.
Like she got into a bag once,
she had like a bag of dog food and just
ate so much that like her,
her whole body was hard.
Like it was the weirdest thing ever.
It's like her stomach was hard.
I was worried about her and she threw up
and then she would eat the throw up.
I mean it's like she couldn't,
she was never satisfied.
Yeah.
And I think it's the same kind of thing
is happening when you leave and when you
come back,
like you walk in literally they're so
happy that you came here because they
can't.
They're like,
they're,
they're eating like,
oh,
I don't know.
Tomorrow may not eat.
He just left.
He's probably not coming back.
Fuck,
I'm fucked.
I'm alone again.
And then all of a sudden you come back.
What the fuck you came back,
you know,
what do you think about some dogs where
they've done tests,
where they show that when owners are
coming home that the dogs respond even
when they're coming home and not normal
hours,
you know,
unusual hours that through hidden
cameras they found that dogs can
anticipate when their,
when their masters are coming home.
I believe it's driving,
driving in their car on the way over
there.
Yeah.
And it's not like a lot of dogs.
I don't think it's,
but it's enough that you know,
you have to go,
well what is this?
What's going on here?
How they smelling it,
copies to let be sleeping on the couch
and then like immediately wake up and
then just sit by the door in like 10
minutes later my girlfriend would walk
in the door.
It was,
oh,
it was always so weird and I always
thought it was just that the time,
because the time was always kind of
around the same time.
He doesn't have a fucking watch,
ridiculous dog like looks around.
He goes,
okay.
When it starts,
the delight,
the big rock that is bright outside goes
down and then he starts playing with
that machine over there that makes the
food,
that kind of proud.
That means like in,
you know,
figures out its own way.
Maybe,
I don't know,
because with these people,
what they showed was hidden camera
footage when they had the dog would like
respond and we'd get up and start
walking around like as the owner was
coming home.
It's a trip,
man.
You wonder.
I mean,
what kind of a weird connection isn't
with dogs?
You know,
they're just always so happy.
Always excited to see you.
This weird fucking relationship you
have,
you know,
they require food from you.
And like what a weird psychic
connection.
You have this strange animal.
They know when you're coming home.
The fuck is going on,
man.
Yeah.
Well who's to say there isn't,
you know,
who's to say,
who knows?
All right.
That's about it,
right?
I guess so.
That's good.
So what it ended up,
where you at,
man,
when's the next time someone could see
you?
And uh,
I'm going to be in Minneapolis some
theater,
some theater.
You don't know where it is.
Fuck,
I don't go to a John Lewis Joie dot
[inaudible] dot com or go to my youtube
page which is youtube.com/j
o n l a j o e dot and they're all there
and I'm going as Jon Jon.
Yeah.
H,
um,
and check it out.
And I have a new video I'm working on.
She'll be out Monday.
Can give us a sneak.
It's guy.
It's called.
I am very super famous.
And is from EMC Vagina.
The guy who brought you,
show me your genitals and I killed
people.
What is this going to be a like Monday
morning.
I'm hoping I'm still editing it now,
but okay.
Everything yourself shoot it.
Directed Edit,
right?
It,
yeah.
That's awesome.
Do you have high as fuck on there?
We're gonna.
End this with highest fuck 'em this
weekend.
Friday night and Sunday night we're
going to be at Sal's comedy whole on
Melrose.
It's a little tiny spot.
It's only like 80 people.
We're just going to go there and fuck
around with Benson's.
Come into a beautiful.
Brian's gonna.
Be there.
A little esther was going to be there.
Who else?
Same Tripoli I called already today.
I haven't talked.
Might be coming to Ari's doing sexual
overtone,
so going to come down.
Awesome.
Jason Tebow.
Very funny.
Um,
so that's it.
Next weekend we're doing Braya the
Improv.
Um,
it will sell out.
So get tickets if you want to get them
in advance.
And then in Australia at Rudy Hill,
that place that I'm doing,
it's a,
it's called an RSL club.
Whatever the fuck that is.
I don't know what that is.
It's like an Italian club or something
like.
Well,
no,
it's like a veterans thing,
like um,
but they just added a second show.
There was a,
an 8:00
show is sold out.
So now there's a 10:00
show and that is Saturday the 26th which
will be like the 25th year or something
like that.
It's real weird.
Like they're like a whole day ahead.
Have you done shows in Australia?
It's fun.
Yeah.
I'm now.
I haven't been,
I haven't been fucking great.
And Sydney's fun.
They don't give a fuck.
The men are men.
The women are women.
It's fucking dangerous animals
everywhere.
There's crocodiles and shit and I love
it there man.
It's a great time when the people are
friendly as fuck.
I,
I enjoy the shit out of it.
Yeah.
So uh,
so that's it.
Um,
tickets go on sale for Seattle.
I'm playing the Moore Theater and uh,
the more theater in,
I think it's in March.
Yes.
March 25th.
They go on sale on Friday.
Alright.
Thank you everybody for everything.
Next week we're going to have a pto.
Hanson,
a very funny comedian from Canada.
Do you know Pete?
I know of him.
I don't know him,
but he's.
Yeah,
he's very funny.
He's,
he'll be here and who knows who else.
And eventually I get Dave Foley and I
got to call boss Rutan and.
Alright bitches.
Um,
that's the end of the show.
Oh thank you.
Fleshlight sponsoring us and keeping the
lights on.
We love you and you love us.
And that's how it should be.
Good to just go to Joe Rogan.net
and click on the leg.
It sounds like my mom just let you keep
me in line.
Go to Joe Rogan.net.
Click on the link and enter in the
Codeword Rogan to get 15 percent off.
All right.
Thank you everybody.
We love you bitches.
Nice.
Thank you.
Joie.
You are the man.
Hi.
It's Bob random room near a dog into
yourself.
Then your dog's looking at you like.
Have you ever been?
Then you can feel your heart fast and
you're convinced that you don't have a
heart attack.
Close Your eyes and you're gonna bomb
the only problems.
And then chicken,
salmon smoked up.
Why did the chicken sandwich thing that
they will know?
You're high.
So you walk around the block time,
go in the store,
but just so you don't know why you're
there.
So you just buy a pack of Gum and get
the hell out of there.
Can Try.
Should have bought some juice and
snacks,
but you too.
Bye.